Õpetaja: Screenshare.
Õpetaja: Lähme. Closehold. Tabs veits Mõtleme, kuhu me üldse Eile jõudsime.
Õpetaja: Aa, serveri võiks käima. Panna Ee, mis siis? Edasi? Ee, me jõudsime eile.
Õpetaja: Tegime mingit taaski. On ju
Õpetaja: Feb Üheteist veeb Ühe üheksa juures vist olime, onju? Ma võtan selle lahti, mis me tegime. Aa, selle pidi tegema. Tõestame ära, et me saame andmed kätte. Mida me ka tegelikult eile tegime. Ju
Õpetaja: Ee, Kui võtta see, mis See vaade iseenesest oli meil.
Õpetaja: Panen korra kõik kinni. Võta siit lahti. Source Views. Ehitasime Atms View vaadet, eksole?
Õpetaja: Oh, mingi rehv on siin Jäänud rehvid minema.
Õpetaja: Ee, on eraldi komponent. Aa By the way ma. Näitan. Midagi mis, ma eile avastasin ee. Mõtlen, et, vahepeal see plugin on ka uuenenud.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui teha lahti See lehekülg ise. Õudsalt mõnus. Ee, kohe paistab. Näete seda asja siin?
Õpetaja: Väike tööriist, see tuleb. See on blugine Uuendus Seda vanasti polnud.
Õpetaja: Kui mõnus on see, et sa saad siit väiksest aknast kohe vaadata, et sa ei pea inspekti lahti tegema.
Õpetaja: Need samad tööriistad on kõik siin olemas. Oota, kus settingus on? See võiks olla tark ka Jah,
Õpetaja: no we talking. Aga veelgi parem on nendest asjadest. Näete see targeting?
Õpetaja: No lähme pangaautomaadid. Siis on kuskilt midagi vaadata.
Õpetaja: Põmm erinevad komponendid.
Õpetaja: Näed, te saate aru Mõttest kui hea Sa saad teda. Vaata, kus miski on.
Õpetaja: Really nice very Nice, Et Ee,
Õpetaja: oota. Kas saaks avada ka? Noh, sa saad kätte mis see Nagu on onju? Ja siis siit saad juba ka kätte, kui vaja. Kas nad koostöös ka töötavad? Ainult üks või teine, on ju?
Õpetaja: Oota, Ma panen selle ka peale.
Õpetaja: Näed, Two, In One ja. Kui ma vajutan näiteks, siia
Õpetaja: ei. Ta, hakkab ikka trigerdama nagu, seda aga, siin on väiksed voetöriistad.
Õpetaja: Ee, edaspidi saab siit nii kiirelt vaadata, mis toimub,
Õpetaja: sest et see inspekt on Niukene hakkab siin nagu tulema ja Laadima Ja et, ee, päris hea.
Õpetaja: Nii pangaautomaadid. Ee, linnad on olemas. Info tuleb meil siis sealt sellest.
Õpetaja: Ee, info tuleb meil siis seal sellest, Ee, ee, stop light ist
Õpetaja: goodnot. Ee, Mis ta siin on? Editor. Aa, see on see. Vaata, et üritan nagu lahti teha seda komponenti. Vaata, editor Is Vanasti see töötas. Nad ütlesid niimoodi. Põmm,
Õpetaja: Me tegi lahti.
Õpetaja: No More. Kas teil ka ei tööta Niikuinii. Kahju, Ee, see oli hea fatuur, aga tegelikult. Noh, kui sa oma projektis kogu aeg toimetad, ega sul piisab sellest vaatenimest ja sa leiad selle ülesse niikuinii Kontrol, Shift Enn otsib faili, on ju? Noh, tuleb, onju?
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes pole pole vahet aga siin, ta kuidagi nagu ütleb, vaata ka vaata midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Okei, mis meil siis on?
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: meil oli see vend ka. Me eile. Siis jäime siis sellise konventsiooni juurde. Et Me, ee, Siin Change I juures koheselt See meetodiblokk. Nüüd võiks ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Selleks pole vajadust. Et see lähenemine on, et me saame ka siit Change iga käivitada meetodeid, mis asuvad siin meetodi blokis.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui on midagi keerulisemat, siis me seda seal soovimegi teha. Kui me saame põhimõtteliselt ühe Reaga ilusti hakkama Limitida siis. Noh, milleks tekitada? Tõesti veel? Lisaks Ühte uut meetodit.
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, et siit läheb jällegi. Vaadake, kus te nagu asju kustutate. Kõige lihtsam on niimoodi, et pange mingisugused asjad nagu kinni Nagu erinevad blokid. Et siis, sa oled nagu lihtsalt kontroll Xiga,
Õpetaja: võtta kogu asja ära turvaliselt
Õpetaja: koos oma alguse lõpuga. Sest siin on alati Iga kord, kui te hakkate tegema niukest asja, et Coopima Cutima Aa, midagi taolist, siis jälgige seda. Aa
Õpetaja: et kui ma praegu niimoodi teeks, mis mis juhtub, siis ma kustutan ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, süntaks läheb katki, Vaata, Et loogiliselt sullud enam ei klapi.
Õpetaja: Ee, need on Maru. Tüütu on tagaajad, eriti siin. Aa, on neid tüütu ajada. Kus Aa,
Õpetaja: ee. Ütleme, Niimoodi, et jaavas on oma niuke süsteem, mis ma hiljem näitan, kui me Jaavasse läheme, et kuidas saab nagu leida ülesse mingisugust tobedat,
Õpetaja: tobedat Sulgemist on kaduma läinud. Ja Kohe esimesel pilgul. Ei ei mõista, nagu kus. No Cloud Võibolla oskaks ka üsna hästi aidata. Vanasti seda abi polnud. Aa et süntaks on katki, Siis ta siis üritab ülesse leida. Aga tegelikult ju süsteemselt lähenedes leiab ise ka alati ülesse. Selle
Õpetaja: Ee, Tuleb üldse lihtsalt nagu proovida asja. Nagu kavalalt teha. Nii, Props, siin on. Cities tuleb alla. Cities tuleb alla selleks, et kõik need opsjonid ära täita. See on see massiiv
Õpetaja: See Electric City Id kontrollib seda, et kui meil on siin mingid valikud, siis me saame City Ga anda alla, et. Hei, sul on küll mingi sisu, aga vali ka nendest üks valik. Meil on tehtud siis, et vali kõik linnad on ju
Õpetaja: sisse tuleb. Esialgu Ee Parentyst. Näete, Selected City Id. Tuleb Paneme siia alla poole, et tema on Child
Õpetaja: on Selected City Id null.
Õpetaja: See antakse siin üleval City Strop Town Ile Kaasa infona See. Voolab siia Valitakse see linn
Õpetaja: ee. Nüüd, ee. Meil, on siin siis see koht, kus on. Ee, see settermeetod. Jällegi tuletan meelde, et siin, on Niukene värk. Et See, kus kohas on kuulaja,
Õpetaja: kuulab sündmust ja käivitab siin selles midagi, et oleks saanud siin ka seda ära progeda. Ee, Selected City It võrdub Event.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga, ee, see On jälle nagu Valikute küsimus. Millal midagi kuidas siis teha sa dollari märki saab? Keegi ütles kontrollsistent. Ee, neli on ju?
Õpetaja: Jah, niimoodi oleks saanud ka teha, Aga praegult ongi meil näiteks see, et meil taask nõudis seda, et ka väike alert on, onju? Siis praegult saakski teha siia väikse Alerdi Alert.
Õpetaja: Seda ei pea tingimata kaas tegema. See prügikasti kaup. Selles mõttes me ei jäta seda igaveseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, võin öelda, et näiteks, et Ee Selected City Id või lihtsalt City Id City Id võrdub pluss S
Õpetaja: Selected.
Õpetaja: Sa Ütled City Id, et iga kord, kui ma nüüd vahetan Seda Dropdown I tuleb teada City Id. Kaks,
Õpetaja: kolm. Noh, mõttes oli see nii nõutud. Nagu
Õpetaja: Nii selle taaski võib tegelikult ee, nüüd lugeda Hetkeseisuga võiks taaski üle ka vaadata. Aga ma juba tean, et. Noh, see kogu sisu oligi.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, Feb üheksa ja compliit, see on See kui mitte ainult buss. Anyway
Õpetaja: Buss Puss
Õpetaja: näinud.
Õpetaja: Mis on järgmine samm? Siis
Õpetaja: Bush ei ole õige sõna me nörg ime. Jah,
Õpetaja: tööde Nagu kokku viimine. Nüüd see saab toimuda ainult pull suunas,
Õpetaja: et me ei saa öelda niimoodi, et. Hei, näed, siin on Master Haru Ee Õpetaja Feb Üheksa Into Master. Sa pead olema selle haru peal, Kui sa tahad muudatusi, sest kui muudatused tulevad sisse, siis sa pead võibolla sealt konflikte hakkama lahendama. Mida iganes saab toimuda ainult aktiivse haru peal.
Õpetaja: Nii et igal juhul ennem tuleb siis teha checkout, mitte Masteri peal, Loomulikult, vaid
Õpetaja: noh, päris elus oleks Master. Päriselus oleks üldse mitte arvutis, vaid
Õpetaja: on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, päriselus. Ee, käib Masteris. See asi ikka niimoodi Ja seal eelkõige see mõte ongi lihtsalt see. Noh, haru ülesse siis panete. Kui te hakkate aitama, siis palun. Lihtsalt. Ee, vaadake, Ee, nagu niimoodi hästi hoolsalt. See on nagu koht kus natuke, pidurit tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Kas see, kas see ikka kõnetab? Teid Arendusarv Into Master Aa, Okei, on Õige
Õpetaja: või tema juba pakub, et üheksa, et kui see arenduseharu on Masters ära möltsitud, siis mis sul sellega enam ikka teha on,
Õpetaja: noh, Me siin toimetamegi meelis. Ee, kes siis ka varsti juba teile tuleb ja räägib Aa Eestile edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle sama. Niiöelda koolituse projekti kallal töötame, siis Ma eile ütlesin talle, et. Kuule, kui sa teed Pull Requestiga neid. Merchi, vaata. Kustutan need harud sealt. Remote St. Ära Hakkavad häirima. Vaata, et kui ma tulen, vaatan niiöelda remote ajal, siis mul on küsimus, kui ma oma remoodil näen. Mingi arenduse arvud, et kas See on nüüd tehtud või ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ei näe seal ühtegi. Kui sa. Kui näed ikka nelja viite, vaata haru, vaata, siis Mõtled, et huvitav, mis seis nendega on? Et kas arendused on ära tehtud? Pilves nad on, on ju? Aga nad. Kas nad ei ole mörsitud. Noh, ütleme väikse projekti puhul. Sul jääb mulje. Vaata, et see on mingi asi, mis on töös,
Õpetaja: aga kui tegelikult on asi juba ära mörsitud, siis nagu tuleb ära kustutada Basic hügieen.
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd on see asi, et. Ee, jällegi see punane joon, et me mölsisime oma niiöelda lokaalses arvutis seda ära
Õpetaja: pilves seda ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me tahame et see, on pilves, siis loomulikult tuleb buss, aga meil on väga lihtne. Kui sa näed noolt, siis kanna hoolt. Seda rohkem ei näe. Onju
Õpetaja: Update Jah, Subdate Live pilves oleks ka.
Õpetaja: No Nüüd Ongi näha. Vaata, kuidas kõik need Working progress. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli videod, asjad. Mis iganes. Kõik minu komited, mis mina siin vahepeal tegin,
Õpetaja: Hetkel on need siin minul Ee, õpetajasse. Nüüd oleks vaja sinna. Ee, remote I ka need Push Ida.
Õpetaja: Ei, ta Kui sa kasutad seda nuppu. Mis on siin, siis sa need käsud, mis siin on? New Branch. Ja kõik need kehtivad aktiivse aru kohta, mille peale oled kui Tuled juba, Klikid siit siis. Noh, siis sa saad nagu valida ka enda nägu, et see on nagu,
Õpetaja: et vahet pole, kas sa, kas Sa tuled, vajutad siit seda. Push I või sa vajutad siit seda. Push I Siis Antud kontekstis on see üks ja sama
Õpetaja: Ee kui Sul on näiteks Niukene. Ma ütlen, mismoodi saab juhtuda. Vaata, et sul on sama nimeline haru Ee, pilves ja oma lokalis ja tuleb näiteks Mingi blokk, et ta ei luba. Näiteks Kujutame ette, et minul on praegult Aa. No mis? Kujutame ette, Vastab tõele, et mul on see õpetaja seal olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui mina kustutaksin oma kohaliku õpetaja. Ära, võtaks masterist uue. Haru ja paneks selle nimeks ka õpetaja, siis ta tegelikult ei ole enam see sama haru, mis on pilves See õpetaja praegult see haru. Ja see, mis on pilves. Noh, võibolla niimoodi on parem näidata See, et
Õpetaja: et need kaks haru, mis mul on, onju. Ee, see ja see
Õpetaja: need tegelikult on. Üks Ja see sama.
Õpetaja: Jah, siis on See, et kustuta kõigepealt see remote I alt ära.
Õpetaja: See, mis siin ja siis saad. Push. Ida, vaata siis. Tal ei ole seda nimekaimu seal ees nii öelda,
Õpetaja: et ta ei saa lükata nagu tegelikult, nagu samanimelist haaru, millega tal ei ole nagu enam Connection It iga selle haaru taga. Taustal on ka mingisugune eriline Id või mis iganes, onju, mis mis genereeritakse, et nad on nagu selles mõttes ee loomise hetkel Niiöelda unikaalsed. Niiöelda,
Õpetaja: et kui on mingisugune asi, mis ee pilves takistab seda pushimist, siis saab selle eest ära kustutada Päris päris arendaja elus Seda, nagu väga niukest olukorda ei tekigi. Aga pigem nagu siin õppevärgis. Vaata, et kustutad ja teed, kuigi see võib juhtuda, oletame, et teed Mingi arenduse haru. Push. Id selle pille.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis on nagu järsku see, et äkki mina seda ei teegi või mida iganes kustutad, endal juba.
Õpetaja: Ee, lokalharu ära ei märka. Ei märka, et pilves on juba olemas. Ja võtad Masteri pealt uue haru ja teed sama nimega Aren saaru. Ja siis, kui hakkad pilve pushima, siis tegelikult on juba midagi. Ja see võib teoreetiliselt juhtuda.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga see oleks siis ma ei Tea, Nagu need lennuõnnetused Vaata, et kõik asjad kuidagi satuvad. Õigel ajal nagu valel ajal õigesti kokku. Vaata ja siis midagi läheb valesti, et Üldjuhul seda ei juhtuks. Kuidas
Õpetaja: maailm?
Õpetaja: Ja siis on see menüüt? Ee,
Õpetaja: et nagu ta ei näidanud olekast, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kustutage lihtsalt Test ära. Kõik sealt remodist ja lihtsalt pushage Siis uuesti. Proage see Sama triki,
Õpetaja: kui vaja. Minge lihtsalt Masteri peale. Võtke õpetajalt uus haru. Vaata, vahepeal lihtsalt liigume edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, järgmine asi.
Õpetaja: Mm Feb. Üheksa. Võib öelda, et see on.
Õpetaja: Paneme selle Done I.
Õpetaja: No jälle mul, Kus vot näed, siin on mingi pilt. Cover, Mul on mingi cover. On mingi Võta ära. Vot super
Õpetaja: superpuper. Ee, Lähen siis tagasi sinna Boardi peale et lihtsalt vaadata, mis on järgmine.
Õpetaja: Järgmine on Feb. Kümme Teeb Kümme mis ta, meile räägib
Õpetaja: vaatame kõigepealt. Ee nüüd. Siin. On, ka mingi cover. Nagu igal pool remu. Cover,
Õpetaja: mis asi see on? Mingi Uusi asi? Nii, oota, võtan võibolla selle pildi või esimesest pildistab Cover I. Väga mõtete asi.
Õpetaja: Miks Miks nad üritavad teha nagu sellest Ee, Chiirast Nagu mingisugust Facebooki? Mingi. Sul on üleval see mingi bänner Ja nüüd varsti tuleb mingi profiilipilt. Ja. Ja kui kaugel ei ole ka see, et saad siin midagi
Õpetaja: Ee, laikida no likida juba saab Nagu nad tahavad tuua mingi My Space I tagasi. Põhimõtteliselt, nagu Sneakilt ei õnnestu. Mina ei lähe sellega kaasa. Andmebaasi Mudel on pannud borderid Sellele peale, võibolla ennast nagu veits häirib.
Õpetaja: Paneme borderid peale. Siis on natukene parem.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee. Andmebaasis Ee tulevad juurde, lisanduvad juurde tabelid image Location Transaction. Type ja Location Transaction Type niuksed. Tabelid tulevad juurde.
Õpetaja: No Vaatame korra. Mis? Siin on ka? Siis Ee, ma korra prooviks nüüd Edit moodist ära minna. Siin all on nüüd see save. See on nagu. Vot see on tobe. Neil et üleval ei ole nuppu, et Ma saaks. Nagu update.
Õpetaja: Ma pean iga kord alles scroll ima näoga. Tehke see asi korda. Mis te nüüd taustapilte? Siia topite?
Õpetaja: Ee, ühesõnaga, Mis siin tabelis on? Meil on location tabel. Kus on siis Location I nimi? Ee Number of Fatms. Mitu automaati seal on number lihtsalt Ee pildi Connection pilditabelisse. Image status ja City Id.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on nii edasi. Ma arvan, et meil on lihtsam praegu vaadata seda sama asja.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda sama asja on lihtsam vaadata siit ee, läbi andmebaasi,
Õpetaja: et meil on location tabel. No vaatame andmeid. Siis on lihtsam. Vaata, on ju minu jaoks. See on muidugi väga hea asi.
Õpetaja: Seda kutsutakse Erd diagrammiks. Siin on muidugi loomulikult, see, et kui sa ütled Erd, Siis see D ongi juba diagramm. See on see klassika. Vaata short end nagu agronüüm, kus viimane täht ja. Ja siis
Õpetaja: kuidas sa nagu Viitad sellele asjale, nagu kattuvad nagu.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas muud moodi öelda? Er diagramm on? Nagu ma ei tea, mingi Emergency room diagramm,
Õpetaja: Ee, siukseid See on kuidas tänapäeval. Ee, nagu representeeritakse andmebaasi mudelit.
Õpetaja: See on üldlevinud tava, et, noh, võib näha mingeid väikseid variatsioone, aga suures pildis on siin sama. Vaata, siin kabu Jalakesed. Me räägime sellest muidugi, siis, kui me andmebaasidest räägime. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: Ee, aga see muidugi annab päris hea pildi ette. Ee, intelligel on ka sisse ehitatud funktsionaalsus. Et sa saad ee näiteks valida Kõik tabelid või osalised tabelid. Parema klõpsu. See on vaatamise koht diagrams
Õpetaja: ja öelda, et joonista mulle diagramm. Aga siin ei ole need joonekesed niimoodi. Ja mummud nagu päris nagu samamoodi, siin on lihtsalt Nooled ei ole neid jalakesi ja asju ei saagi olla, sest et tegelikult osad nendest asjadest on tegelikult mõttelised andmetes, need ei peegeldu,
Õpetaja: siin on mõeldud nagu mõte ja soov. Nagu. Vaata, et kuidas me nagu selles süsteemis andmeid hoiame niiöelda need mummud, just mis siin on, nendega, on Niimoodi et seda tegelikult andmetes tingimata ei saa nagu peegeldada.
Õpetaja: Nii et siit saab ka nagu mingisuguse diagrammi ette. Põhimõtteliselt, kui me võtame Location Tabeli näete? Location Tabelis on viide City tabelile Siin on. Näete seda sinist.
Õpetaja: Ma saan Zoom. Ida, Näete seda sinist Võite It Location Il on oma It. See on tema Primer I gee. Aga siin on võõrvõti, et siin tabelis Hoiame. Numbrit. Mis Viitab
Õpetaja: City Tabeli Primer I Key le
Õpetaja: vastupidi on ka. On ju, et näiteks Location images on viide Location Id Le ja siin on see sama informatsioon tegelikult Nagu, ee, olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla natuke peegeldatud kujul, Aga ta on enamvähem nagu, Noh, ta on natuke lihtsustatud kujul, aga ta on olemas, kui Me vaatame pärisandmeid. Siis hakkab nagu see asi välja tulema. Meil on siin sikupilli prisma
Õpetaja: number. Of Htm, see staatus, Need kõik on täidetavad väljad. Aga kas see on täidetav? Väli City Id? Vaimsad väljad, mis ei ole täidetavad, On see näiteks, kui ma teen uue rea, näiteks Andmebaas juba teab, et seda genereeritakse ise.
Õpetaja: Need väljad on kõik kohustuslikud. Väljad. Nal ei saa jääda, kui ma panen näiteks siia copil teksti siia. Üritan seda niiöelda Lisatabelisse. Siis ta ütleb Ee
Õpetaja: City Id välju. Ei saa olla null
Õpetaja: nal nagu tühjus, et sa pead siia panema.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui. Mina paneksin siia, Näiteks. Ee. No öelge mul, mis see linnamehel on. Üldse ma ruttu vaatan seda Ka Ee, kui ma teen lahti. City Tabeli. Meil on Tallinn Tartu pärnu. No öelge ruttu. Üks asukoht kuskil. Ee, pärnus.
Õpetaja: Noh, väga originaalne.
Õpetaja: Ee, pärnu kaubamaja.
Õpetaja: Nii pärnu Kaubamaja, siis tema City Id peaks olema.
Õpetaja: Palun kolm.
Õpetaja: Ah, kolm, üks, üks.
Õpetaja: Ei ole ju. Näete, on kolm pärnul et siin peaks panema Kolm
Õpetaja: saate mõtteliselt aru. Need andmed on omavahel ühendatud. Nüüd ta lubaks seda sinna panna. Näed pärnu kaubamaja tekkis
Õpetaja: aga nüüd on veel siin andmeid siin on, niimoodi, et igal sellel Location Il
Õpetaja: Ee saab olla Aa pilt. Esiteks, Aa, läheme korra Tabelisse. No siin ei ole praegu ühtegi pilti. Aga kui me kujutaksime ette, et siin oleks pilt,
Õpetaja: siis nüüd mina küsin. Kui mina tahaksin pärnu. Ee Pärnu ma panen selle siia alla. Kui mina tahaks pärnu kaubamajale panna pilti, siis need andmed tuleks siia. Tähed. Lihtsalt kujutame ette. Ma küsin, mis saaks olema. Location Id.
Õpetaja: Me ei saa seda isegi valida. Aga mis saaks, oleks Location Eddy
Õpetaja: Neli, Sest et see on location. See on veel ee, it Pärnu Kaubamaja on neli. Siia tuleks lihtsalt neli.
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa seda täita, sest et siin on väga spetsiifilisel moel, aga kujutage ette, vaata siia saaks panna Pildi info.
Õpetaja: Pilt on ka ju andmed. Vaata, ei ole, niimoodi. Et Ee, Tahad Lisada pilte endale? Facebooki? Lükkad kuskil seal läpaka vahelt nagu mingi päris pildi sisse. Ja siis kuidagi läheb mingi aatomiosadeks ja läheb sealt mööda sidekaableid kuhugi teisele poole ja muutub maagiliselt Päris pildiks tagasi Pilt on samamoodi. Andmed,
Õpetaja: nullid ja ühe päeva lõpuks. Okei,
Õpetaja: No on Niukene tabel ka vaata mis veel on Aa siis ütles Ja on olemas Niuke asi nagu
Õpetaja: Location Transaction Type. Võtame selle siia. Lahti. Enam tegema. Võtan selle lahti ja panen siia alla. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: See nüüd on vahetabel. Vaadake, ee, kui me vaatame praegult kas ma seda suuremaks panna, Kui me vaatame praegu, et see on Location tabel,
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et vaata Ka need noored näitavad, et minu kasutatud kuskil see suund on, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: See tegelikult on täpsemalt niimoodi. Siin on öeldud seda. Vaata, et ühel Location Il saab olla Mitu Location Transaction Type I. Vaadake seda neid harusid.
Õpetaja: Ühel selle tabeli real ühel selle Tabeli real. Ühel suvalisel Real.
Õpetaja: Seda sama rida saab siin määrata mitmeid kordi. Miks näete? Sellepärast me hoiame selles tabelis Location Ee Location id Võtmeväärtust
Õpetaja: Number Lihtsalt kui minul on Mis Location oli? Meil siis pärnu kaubamaja.
Õpetaja: Neli. Me saame sii. Siin on veel, kui saab panna selle Seda number nelja. Aga seda number nelja saab üle mitme rea panna. Nii mitu korda, kui tahad. Teine asi on Transaction Type
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Il on ka. See on üks tabel. Kus On Ko? Kolm erinevat Transaction Type I sularaha sisse. Sularaha välja Maksed samamoodi. Nendel on kõigil Id. Ja see siin on seost tabel.
Õpetaja: See on mitu mitmele suhe?
Õpetaja: Vaata, siin on ühel pildil saab olla mitu location It
Õpetaja: idee järgi See on tegelikult. Saad sa bullshit. See peaks olema teistpidi Igal juhul. Minu meelest meie tabelis ongi teistpidi. See on vana pilt,
Õpetaja: Meil on hoopis niimoodi. Vaata, et üht ühel Location Il saab olla. Mitu pilti idee järgi ei pea,
Õpetaja: aga andmete mõttes nad on seotud niikuinii niimoodi, et on võimalik,
Õpetaja: et need need näitavad seda suunda. Kurat, selle peaks korda tegema mingi aeg.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ee, ma isegi ei tea, kuidas ma Just olen seda muutnud. Ee, mulle vanasti. Mulle meeldis niimoodi teha, sest, et see on väga mugav, aga see on väga, väga vale
Õpetaja: Ee Või noh, ma ei tea, kas ta vale on. Just, aga
Õpetaja: aga kuidas kui sa selle lahti ee räägiksid, selle seda
Õpetaja: praegu valetada see Ma ei tea, kuidas see vä.
Õpetaja: Nojah, see joon, mis nende kahe kasti vahel ei taha Seda rääkida. Ma tahaks rääkida siis, kui me Räägime andmebaasidest ja me teeme mingeid harjutusi, sest on lihtsam teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal ei Ole Brad Point I.
Õpetaja: Ee, Vaatame. Parem proovime saada praegusest Etapist aru. Ühesõnaga, nende siin on niimoodi, et see siin sõna otseses mõttes on ee vahetabel. Ma tõstan ta korra tagasi siia ja panen ta siia vahele. Ee, paneme niimoodi, et ta on siin keskel? Noh, esialgu ta on all.
Õpetaja: Meil on olemas location Id ja nendel on Id D.
Õpetaja: Noh, niimoodi vist saab kuidagi valida. Ka vä
Õpetaja: ei saa korraga Valida on Location Id ja nende Id D.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see Vahetabel, aga ma teen nüüd lahti ka. Transaction Type I Ee lahti.
Õpetaja: Topin ta siia kõrvale. Seal ka. Panen siia alla, Paneme selle kinni, teeme. Nüüd on mul kolm tabelit
Õpetaja: natuke halba vaadata, aga nii on.
Õpetaja: Teevad ka seda suuremaks. Siin, mine siiapoole.
Õpetaja: Natukene väiksemaks kõik ka tabeleid ka. Oi, oi, oi, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Jah, võtame sellise test ära.
Õpetaja: No mis meid Aitab? Oota, Paneme natukene kinni. Neid asju kõrval, mis ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Nii, ootage ära. Aga tee niimoodi. Võtame niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Teeme niimoodi ja siis ei Tegelt. Hoopis Teeb niimoodi. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi niimoodi
Õpetaja: krab
Õpetaja: üks tabel, Teine tabel.
Õpetaja: Ahhaa, kust on värve? Ka Ee, ütleme niimoodi, et see on punane.
Õpetaja: See on roheline ja viimane on Ee sinine.
Õpetaja: Jah, siin Tabelis hoitakse.
Õpetaja: See see vahetabel. Ee, niiöelda hoiab neid numbreid
Õpetaja: Nii, selles teises tabelis mängivad rolli need numbrid.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd selles tabelis siin Facebook
Õpetaja: Oota, Roheline.
Õpetaja: Oli see roheline momentaariumist ma valisin.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin tabelis praegu sõna otseses mõttes. Need ühed tulevad sellest sikupilli prismast mitu rida on Ühega
Õpetaja: kolm rida. Aga vaadake, see on üks mitmele. Vaata, Location is. On Meil üks rida seda sama. Sellele samale numbrilt on saab mitu korda viidata siin tabelis.
Õpetaja: See on juba sisse kirjutatud. Niipea, kui see veerg on olemas, siis on võimalik nii teha
Õpetaja: üks mitmele Siin on võimalik teha, et meil on mitu rida, mis viitavad siin ühele reale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, siin selle teise tabeliga on samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Näete, see üks viitab sellele,
Õpetaja: ka, et siin on natuke. Siin on number Kolm on siin all. See kaks viitab sellele.
Õpetaja: See kolm viitab sellele.
Õpetaja: Siin on võimalik luua Omavaheliseid seoseid,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: See on seostabel.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me vaatame neid jooni ka, vaata siin seda ühte rida siin. Idee järgi saaks ka olla seda ühte. Mitu korda? Vaata näiteks raha sisse. Raha sisse, raha sisse. Aga lihtsalt siin. Ei ole see vaja. Nagu
Õpetaja: kui me nüüd Vaatame seda joonist. Siis nii ongi Näete. Location Tabeli ühte. Ühte. Seda Primer I. D saab siin tabelis mitmeid kordi panna, kui tahad
Õpetaja: ja Samamoodi on transaction Type Il. Tegelikult, mul on mingi Id siin. Ja ma saan siia veergu panna. Transaction Type Id sse nii palju neid Kui ma tahan panna.
Õpetaja: See on seos tabel. See keskmine tabel ühendab kahte tabelit
Õpetaja: kui klassikaliselt. Ee, niukest vahetabelit, teha see on lihtsalt see, et meil on mitu mitmele ühel location Il
Õpetaja: saab olla mitu transactions It i
Õpetaja: sularaha sisse sularaha välja ja ühel transaction type il saab olla mitu location it.
Õpetaja: No kui mina tahan panna näiteks, et sikupilli prismas on ee raha sisse, raha välja ja maksed, siis ma seda teengi. Vaata niimoodi
Õpetaja: ja see sama raha sisse saab olla nii sikupilliprismas tondiselveris ja pärnu kaubamajas. Meil ongi vaja mitu mitmele suhet? Vaata,
Õpetaja: et Me. Me saame mõlemaid kasutada. Mitu mitmele. Noh, see loksub paika hiljem. Pärast. Okei?
Õpetaja: Need tabelid tulevad juurde.
Õpetaja: Täiendav Atms vaadet pangaautomaatide asukohtade tabeliga tuleb juurde. Selline asi, mis siin on. Siin on Ware Clean. Asukoht teenused.
Õpetaja: Need andmed on meil andmebaasis olemas.
Õpetaja: Mis aus Komponent tabelis on? Kolmjärgnevat veergu hinnasukoht. Teenused Tabel täidetakse automaatselt. Ee,
Õpetaja: moodi Nii, ee,
Õpetaja: on kavalamat. Appi, nii persse.
Õpetaja: Vale. Asi onju
Õpetaja: natuke ruttu. Kes on veel Kuskil siin ka.
Õpetaja: Miks nii nuga läks? Paigast ära. Ka? Vaata, siin on õige
Õpetaja: rohkem. Ei, ole. Nii, Ee, Vot kui ma tahaks minna Vihuma uudiste on natukene lubab pilte paremini vaadata ja Nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Tabel täidetakse automaatselt Atm st leheküljele maandades. No mis on siin See Võtmesõna Me läheme, maandume ühele lehele.
Õpetaja: Automaatselt täidetakse tabel. Mis see meile tähendab?
Õpetaja: Koodi tasandil.
Õpetaja: View View View komponendis.
Õpetaja: Aa, seda küll, aga Vaata, siin on Tabel, Täidetakse automaatselt leheküljele maandudes.
Õpetaja: Kes on meie see, abimees? Tööriist, kes ait mounted Before aitab, et automaatselt käivitame et tuleb siis tuua need andmed ära onju?
Õpetaja: Maandumiseni, mis meil tegelikult on ju alles. Ee, seal on valik see, et kõik linnad ehk et siis ongi kogu See kõik automaadid, mis me ronime.
Õpetaja: No siin sellest, nagu vähemalt näitas. Nii on,
Õpetaja: Kui me. Kui me tahaksime seda, et ei näidata nagu Mitte midagi siis Me saaksime niimoodi ka progeda. Aga lihtsalt kasutaja oleks nagu. Võibolla tüütu, onju, et
Õpetaja: ta võibolla tahabki kõike näha. Või ta Alguspunkt tundub loogiline. See on ka enda see, et vaata, kui paned nagu filtreeritud kujul, et lähed kuskile, et veebilehele, et näita mulle pesumasinaid.
Õpetaja: Väga veider oleks niimoodi. Vaata, et lähed sinna, on ju? Ja siis on tühjus, et nüüd vali. Kas soovid nüüd siin mingi Samsung või Mis iganes, vaata, onju, et sa ikka näed ju kõike, On ju
Õpetaja: see esimene?
Õpetaja: Jah, näita kõike. Tavaliselt on ju? Vaata, Niukene filtreerimine on Kitsendamine, onju, et alguses näed rohkem. Ja siis ma ei tea. Paned mingi otsingusõna või kasutad seal hinnavahemikku või mida iganes, on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, Võibolla hinnavaatus. Punkt E E. Oleks Niukene Hea näide kohe
Õpetaja: Tabeli täitmiseks Vajalik info saadetakse Back and teenuse Gtip ja Adem Location Session Vastusest Kaasa antakse Parameeter City Id
Õpetaja: esialgsel leheküljel maandud, et saadetakse Backendile sõnum Kett, Ee, bla, blabla. Nii et kaasa antakse Parameeter City id väärtust Null. Siin öeldakse ka, et esimene esimene sõnum, mis maandudes läheb on null. Mäletate, mis null on meil seal? Dropdown, is, Kõik linnad
Õpetaja: Ee, Lisa linna rippmenüü järgi andmete filtreerimine.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui sina valitsid City Id kaks, mis tähendab Tallinnat, siis peaks nägema ainult
Õpetaja: Tallinna Äsja edukas Päring kasuta valib linnade ritmenüst mingi linna, mille peale käivitatakse kett.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma pean seda korda tegema. Ma ei saa niimoodi jätta. Seda,
Õpetaja: Kus see nüüd oli. Kuskil oli nüüd siin puudu. Kalvkriips siin.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: taas see. Niimoodi aja jooksul täieneb. Ee, siin seal ikka võib ka veel mingeid vigu leida. See kahjuks käib selle asjaga kaasas, kus me jäime oma asjaga
Õpetaja: Siia jäimegi. Nii
Õpetaja: ee bla, blabla, andmete laadimine, nii et Andmetele antakse City Id. Väärtus kasutaja valib linnade mingi linna. Siis peab midagi uuesti käivituma.
Õpetaja: Mäletate, meil see meetod Set City Id,
Õpetaja: nagu et alt midagi valid. Ülesse saadetakse
Õpetaja: Ee City Id. Hetkel Ee Väärtustame niiöelda ära seal, et uus on väärtusega. Mis iganes alt tuleb, mis voolab Uuesti alla, on ju? Ja praegu tuleb lihtsalt alert. Aga nüüd peab midagi muud käivituma. Vaata, nüüd on see, et nüüd me peame laadima selle sama teenuse järgi uuesti andmed.
Õpetaja: Aga seekord juba siis niimoodi, Et, ee, läheb
Õpetaja: see City Id kaasa. Ja Backend peaks siis tagastama meile Sellised andmed, kus on ainult need linnad, mis me valisime
Õpetaja: vastavalt City väärtusele, tagastatakse vastava linna pangaautode Info Kui City. On null, siis tagatakse kõik linnad. Noh, kui ma lähen tagasi jälle kõik linnad peale, siis ma tahan jälle näha kõiki, onju?
Õpetaja: No selline näide, siis ka Respons Bodist, et siis on selline struktuur.
Õpetaja: Location Id Location name. Vaadake, mis see siin on.
Õpetaja: Massiiv massiivi sees on objektid. See on üks objekt
Õpetaja: Selle objekti sees on Location Id Location Name Cityname ja vaadake, mis nüüd tuleb. Nüüd tuleb võti Transaction types.
Õpetaja: Tema ei ole lihtsalt string, Tema Ei, ole lihtsalt Aa. Mingi number, mis tema on? Ta on nüüd omakorda massiiv.
Õpetaja: Siin on sees objektid kus on lihtsalt üks väli Transaction Type Name. Ja kus on siis väärtus? Raha sisse ka välja maksab. See peegeldab seda. Saate aru.
Õpetaja: Väga tore. No ja siin on Siis näide ka. Vaata sikupilliprisma. Tondiselver Jõeprisma, mis kattub selle näite. Ka, Vaata, et nagu see, kui vaadata seda kogu varianti, et siin on Kolm asja. Siin on kaks asja. Siin on kaks asja ei mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, vea. Vastus. Programmeeritud viga,
Õpetaja: Error kood kaks, kaks. Ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati. No klassikaliselt Pigem näidatakse lihtsalt tühja tabelit. Viga ei visata
Õpetaja: nagu tühja tabelit näiteks. Et, noh, ma ei, tea, peerud on, aga Kui sa hakkad kuidagi järsku kitsendama hinnavaatluses, Vaata, onju või kus iganes, et noh otsin. Mingit uut telekat. Ee,
Õpetaja: laius kuuskümmend viis tolli. Vaata, Onju? Alguses, nagu midagi pakub, pakub.
Õpetaja: Paned järsku, et. Noh, kuni viissada Euri, vaata, siis vaatad, et mis toimub nagu ühtegi, tabel on tühi, Ei tule ühtegi vastust. Tavaliselt ei tule teadet. Nagu, kuule, et ei leidnud ühtegi Ee, toodet. Vaata, onju, aga me lihtsalt õppimise mõttes lihtsalt Soovime, et ta on siis Niuke lahendus.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on pigem hoopis see. Näiteks, et. Ee, siia. Ütleme niimoodi, et meil on rippmenüü kõikide Linnade kohta, aga polegi kõiki asukohti. Ma mõtlen, et meie süsteem alustab.
Õpetaja: Me ei taha nagu seda, teha, et me hakkame aja jooksul panema linnasi juurde. See on lihtsalt kolm, linna, et hoida asja nagu väiksena, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga kujutage ette. Vaata, et mind nagu temal peab olema võimalus näha kõiki linnasid ja siis lisada süsteemi. Vaatad sa nagu küsid. See on nagu See on valikuteline küsimus. See on arhitektuur.
Õpetaja: Kas me Näitame dropdown is. Ainult neid linnu, mis on üldse olemas Ja kus on vastuseid, on ju? Või seal on kõik linnad ja on okei. Vaata see, et tuleb, et noh, pole. Vaata, onju. Ma ütlengi pä päriselus. Tavaliselt pigem on see lähenemine, et lihtsalt tabel jääb tühjaks, kui Valid mingi valiku, Paned kitsendavaid tingimusi,
Õpetaja: ei leia midagi. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: Me lihtsalt. On siin sellepärast, et saaks midagi natuke õppida. Vigade viskamist, See on natuke tehislik siin Selles mõttes see on. Seda pole vaja. Front saaks sellega väga hästi, Kui isegi see soov oleks näidata, mis Tavaliselt on. Vaata, kui meile taga tagastatakse mingit massiivi,
Õpetaja: et väga okei on saada tühi massiiv.
Õpetaja: Noh, loop is Ütled, et nüüd tulevad need Read, mis tulevad sealt massiivist.
Õpetaja: Kui massiivs on null elementi, Noh, mitu rida tuleb
Õpetaja: null? Noh, see on Fine, vaata onju, Ee, et see, On natukene siin selles mõttes tehislik. Lihtsalt et õppida Backendi poole peal midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, rohkem, et et oleks seda kordust
Õpetaja: kui saadakse nelisada, neli viga. Kakssada kaks, siis Kuvada sõnumist saadud messed, veateadet. No me oleme midagi taolist teinud. Kõikide teiste errorite puhul suunata. Kasutada Error View vaatajale Ups, midagi läheks valesti,
Õpetaja: sest et alati võib midagi minna valesti ja lähebki kasutaja lihtsalt muidu tooksiks mingeid asju ja võibolla ta ei saagi aru. Vaata, et midagi on totaalselt vussis. Ja kui ühtegi asja saad aru, kui ikka sõnumid ei saa oma vastuseid siis mida kuradit me Seal näitame. Frontis. Vaata,
Õpetaja: me peame kuidagi nagu kasutajale midagigi ütlema. Vaata, et ta saab aru, et midagi on katki.
Õpetaja: Ta ei saa seda kasutada või saab osaliselt kasutada. Noh, kõik on programmisse küsimus.
Õpetaja: Nii Davaika. Ee, hakkame siis ee. Toimetama. Ee, millest siis Nagu alustame?
Õpetaja: Pange korra selle asja üldse. Kinni. See käib Pinda mulle veits. Siin
Õpetaja: teeme kõigepealt uue haru. Mina panen nüüd Ee, need andmed siin kinni. Taustal kasutasime Neid näitena. Igaüks teeb endale ühe uue haru. New Bransform õpetaja. Kümme. Oli
Õpetaja: peeb kümme
Õpetaja: Ee
Õpetaja: lisa. Uus. Tabeli komponent Ee tabelis On kolm Alljärgnevat veergu Andmed saadakse Atm Locations teenusega. Okei, no
Õpetaja: kust? Alustame siis komponente alla. Uu,
Õpetaja: see oleks mõeldav, aga Mina ei tahaks teha nii. Miks Eile just vaatasime? Nagu
Õpetaja: miks, miks, Ee, Kui me hakkame seda tegema, siis nüüd läheb käsitsi progemiseks, onju? Tee need failid, tee need Propsid ja me võime seda teha, kui see on niimoodi selgem. Vaata, me võime seda teha. Ka. A. Teine variant on see, et me Teeme, mida?
Õpetaja: Läheme oma vaatesse. Teeme selle visuaali valmis. Võibolla kasutame ka mingisuguseid muutuja nimesid ja siis ekstrakt.
Õpetaja: Uue komponent.
Õpetaja: Saame kohe kõik selle asja nii nagu vaja,
Õpetaja: Aga ma pakun, et Davai teeme. Seekord veel teeme.
Õpetaja: Ma nõustun, see on parem. Variant. Aga Võiks teistmoodi ka teha. Noh, see sellel on oma. Pluss on jälle see. Vaata, et me peame siis natuke rohkem mõtlema. Vaata, et, oot, kuidas. Kuidas see, kuidas Täpselt käis niukse komponendi tegemine, kus on,
Õpetaja: kus tuleb ka mingi info sisse ja nii edasi. Vaata, on ju aga aega on meil vähe, Nii et sellepärast, ma ikkagi teeks Pigem nii natukene. Oleme asjadega maas, aga ärme muretse,
Õpetaja: Aega on ee, kuna üks valik teeprojekt oli väga Lahe aega on, oli projekti ja brändi nimi,
Õpetaja: mis keskendus sellele, et kui sa ära sured,
Õpetaja: siis sa tahad Võibolla nagu Deed Man Switch, Vaata, et sa tahad Trigerdada sõnumeid oma kallimatele,
Õpetaja: teateid ja faile ja videosid ja pilte,
Õpetaja: et nad hakkaksid võibolla ka oma sünnipäevadel midagi saama. Mingi niuke projekt oli omamoodi päris huvitav,
Õpetaja: et sa pead kogu aeg mingi teatud aja tagant nagu andma märku, et sa oled elus süsteem Ise süsteemis süsteemis on pandud, Siis vaata On ju, et mis intervalli tagant sa nagu küsid,
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa üks hetk ei vasta talle, Siis ta trigerdab automaatselt sinu sätestatud emailid ja annab ligipääsu sellele süsteemile,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, siis saad hakata vaatama. Mingeid asju hakkad Tulema, pärast,
Õpetaja: Jah, Tuleb eemalt, et, ee. Meie kaastunne.
Õpetaja: Et Ee, isa lahkus.
Õpetaja: Midagi ei ole teha aga tule meie portaalil aega. On. Aeg On veel temaga Nagu veits. Nagu vaadata, et nad tegid igast asja sinna, et said vaba vaba kavas sinna panna mingi igast asju, et
Õpetaja: jah, Black Mirror Juba nagu. Kes on selle sarja vaadanud.
Õpetaja: Osaliselt. No seal on Niuke Niuke osa. Kus on see mingi
Õpetaja: ee, eelmiste eelmiste inimestega kes on lahkunud. Ja robot, kui lõpus ka tagasi tuua näed. Aga kas nad ikka on siis see päris sama inimene on ju Hea küll, kuule Lähme edasi, ärme aruta Siin midagi. Arutame ainult koodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, arutasime siis, seda et me ei hakka tegema seda lähenemist tegema et me teeme Eraldi komponendi. Meil on see lõppplaan kindlalt komponendina teha. Aga nüüd on pigem, see, et kus see komponent tuleb, on küsimus ja mis see peab tulema. On see nagu.
Õpetaja: Mis peab siia tulema.
Õpetaja: Aha, Tabel. Kuhu see peab tulema?
Õpetaja: Kui me võtame niimoodi. Paigutust, siis on meil
Õpetaja: jaa No lähme vaatame kõigepealt, kuhu me saaks seda panna. Me saame panna lihtsalt. Kas kommentaari või mida iganes place,
Õpetaja: et me peame nüüd otsima ülesse, et ee, kuhu? Kuhu ta läheb? Nagu kui me tuleme, siis me saame aru, et siin on Niukene setup, onju, et meil on Üks Row ja üks, kolm. Vaata, kus on pangaautomaadid Header. Siis tuleb järgmine. Nad on selles mõttes, et sa pead aru saama, et nad on üks Row, Onju, Ta on ühel joonel. Vähemalt ülemise joone mõttes.
Õpetaja: Nad on ühe ro sees, Aga kaks eraldi kolumnit, kui me otsime oma Selle esimene Rome. Ei, huvita
Õpetaja: teine ruum. Meid huvitab Ja me näeme, et meil on siin üks kool siin. Järelikult peaks tulema üks kool juurde, onju?
Õpetaja: Siis, mis me saame teha, on selle, et paneme selle siit eest kinni niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et võtame ta nagu eest ära, et Selle City strop Downiga. Hetkel ei ole midagi teha. Mis ma siia kirjutan,
Õpetaja: Tab Enter. Ja mis ma nüüd kirjutan? Siia, sisse, Glass Call
Õpetaja: Nii, no võibolla laiust veel Ei, anna. Pärast tegeleme sellega hetkel. Tegelikult mitte midagi veel ei muutu
Õpetaja: meie jaoks, sest siin pole midagi, Aga Kui sa paned siia juba mingid tähed, onju, siis sa juba saad. Aru Vaata, et hakkab tulema midagi,
Õpetaja: Okei? Mis see tulema peab,
Õpetaja: Tabel On ju Mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Kas on see mõte, Etable pluss või
Õpetaja: Boots Trap. Mis tahes element on? Nagu vaatame, äkki mingi mingi asi on juba olemas. Seal, seal. Võibolla mõnes kohas ei ole ka väga palju. Mingid väikseid kujundid või mingid varjundid. Või Mingid asjad, Vaata, mingi onju?
Õpetaja: Aga ta saab olema kindlasti parem, kui see meie templeid, kus pole siin Bordereid, on ju? No, see on ikka monster. Nagu asi, Mida otsida Ka tulen, teeme lahti. Ta läheb sinna, Le. Aga meie paneme table.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Kuidas siin töötab, on see, et siin on siis See üks näidis niiöelda nendest lehtedest, et siin on kogu kood tabelist, mille me kavatseme võtta. Ja edaspidi ta hakkab näitama, et kuule siin Ee, headerist Niiöelda sellest. Pane Primer I, Kui tahad sinist
Õpetaja: ja nii edasi. Aa, kui tahad, siis sa pead muutma nagu ainult seda kõige ülemist rida Koodis saate aru. Ta ei. Ta ei anna kogu koodi uuesti koos andmetega, vaid ühe korra üleval annab selle kogu koodi siia. Me tuleme, paneme copy.
Õpetaja: Näete seda table? Siis tuleb siia. Võib lüüa paar tühja rida, et tal võibolla veits paistab esialgu rohkem välja.
Õpetaja: See Nüüd on meie table.
Õpetaja: Nii. Aga nüüd me saame isegi seda juba vaadata ka, et tuli siia mingid niuksed asjad, aga nüüd on nagu See, et võibolla see stiil ei ole See meie lemmik. Pole mingeid varjundeid ega midagi,
Õpetaja: et nüüd me saame nagu siin,
Õpetaja: tähendab, tõmbab selle korra kokku, Nagu et ei ole seda muud mudru hetkel vaja vaadata, et me saame nagu selles, defineerida tema visuaali. Ja nüüd me lihtsalt Peame otsustama, et mida me tahame. Mingit sinist ma ei taha. Stripe oleks mõeldav Kolumnid
Õpetaja: must üldse mustad. Mingid veerud on nagu ka niimoodi Omavahel tehtud, mitte read, et siin on igast varianti. Aga minule meeldib tavaliselt see
Õpetaja: tark.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin Kood on alati all. Pool Vaata Näide on Siin Kood on alg. Table Dark Table Hover teeks näiteks niukse disaini,
Õpetaja: et meil ei ole niimoodi, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, siis me tulemegi siia, Table Dark Table.
Õpetaja: Noh, ostad ka hover.
Õpetaja: Ah, palun.
Õpetaja: Ja rohkem ei olegi midagi nagu tuled siia ja on midagi niimoodi. Noh,
Õpetaja: ainuke mingi Mustvalge disain on veits siin nagu mingi mingi niukene värk.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd natukene aega Saame siin siin lehel niiöelda progeda, ennem kui me teeme sellest komponendi Senikaua, kuni siin sees midagi klikkima ei hakka,
Õpetaja: siis. Ja ja mingeid meetodeid käivitama, siis senikaua saame panna siin enne kui me ekstrakti. Me viime ta eraldi komponendiks. Praegult on ju mõnus siin toimetada. Kõik on siin nähtaval ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Toimetame siis praegult natukene siin oma töödest te saategi teha Lihtsalt võltsandmetega Lihtsalt mingi paar näidet jätta ära. Te võite nagu otsast lõpuni ühe lehe tegelikult ära disainida, enne Kui te üldse hakate mingit funktsionaalsust tegema mingit datamuutujaid ja asju, vaata saate panna paika mingi menüü. Noh, pane paarit sinna. Mingi, Mis teil Seal on on ju,
Õpetaja: et, ee, lihtsalt on midagi visuaalis olemas. Te panete kõik paika. Progemise rõõm, et. Noh, kus me andmed toome ja Mis komponendid me teeme Ja nii edasi. On ju, et, ee, saate näiteks niimoodi teha?
Õpetaja: Nii, Ee, aga nüüd ongi. Noh, peame siis tegema, Mis meil meil loomulikult ei ole. First last ja handel. Ee, andmetes, et me nüüd peaks hakkama seda natukene mudima kõigepealt visuaali pealt,
Õpetaja: et Vaatame, mis taaski ütleb.
Õpetaja: Ee, vale asi. See siin hoopis. Nii Ee, Heederil peavad olema linna asukoht. Teenused, linn, asukoht, teenused.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis kõige lihtsam on. Tal on siin selles disainis, Muidu, mis meil siin on?
Õpetaja: Mingi numbriloetelu on meil kokku tulebki kolm veergu. Ma pakun, et kustutame selle ühe heederi ära.
Õpetaja: Esimene Row on need. Noh, nüüd on nüüd See visuaal on mingi niukene, on ju Thats Fine, Miks tal on Kolm headerit.
Õpetaja: Aga on tal ka. Vaata nagu neid Rose on. Vaata, nagu neli.
Õpetaja: Muudame kõigepealt lihtsalt nime. Teeme Step by Step. Ee, mis Siin oli linn.
Õpetaja: Ee, linn Asukoht, teenused, linn, asukoht
Õpetaja: teenused.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma. Nüüd küsin teie käest, et mitut rida meil tegelikult oleks nüüd vaja siin üldse.
Õpetaja: No ei, me ei tea ju, mitut rida on vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga mitut rida? Progemiseks on meil vaja
Õpetaja: ühte ainust sest et see Esimene rida, mida me kasutame selle selle elemendi pealt. Dünaamiliselt tulevad kordused vastavad. Ee, siis nagu andmete massiivile, et meil tegelikult enda näidiseks on vaja reaalselt ainult ühte rida,
Õpetaja: sest et see rida, siis hakkabki olema see, mida me tegelikult dünaamiliselt kordame ja teeme nii mitu korda, kui Meil on massiivi subjekte.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui me tuleme siia alla poole. Siin on nagu üks rida, et te saate kokku tõmmata üks rida, Teine rida. Kolmas Rida on nii?
Õpetaja: No kustutame need kaks rida ära
Õpetaja: ja nüüd peaks jääma. Meil Ainult üks rida on üks rida.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd teeme selle lahti, Siis meil on siin neli veergu.
Õpetaja: Kustutame selle esimese. Ära. Mis on mingi Ee, natuke Boldis ka oleks olnud saanud visuaalselt. Nüüd on meil linn, asukoht, Teenused. Me võime nüüd siin enda mugavuseks praegult täita ära panna. Mingisugused andmed.
Õpetaja: Näiteks Tallinn
Õpetaja: on Tallinn asukoht.
Õpetaja: No paneme siku pilli prisma.
Õpetaja: Siku pilliprisma on nii?
Õpetaja: Teeme selle ühe näidise. Täitsa nagu ette. Ära. Ee, kui me vaatame Ka Järgmisena peaks tulema. Teenuste all peaks tulema kolm rida sularaha sisse. Sularaha Väljamaksed on nii?
Õpetaja: No kui ma tulen siia viimasesse veergu, et siia ma Nüüd tahan kolme rida. Saada eesmärgiga sularaha sisse.
Õpetaja: Okei, sulahara sisse. Nüüd öelge, tee mulle, kuidas ma saan siia nüüd alla veel sulehara sisse Sulahara välja maksad.
Õpetaja: Sest et kui ma kirjutan siia, kui ma võtan siia entri, Näiteks kui ma teen mingit niukest asja, näiteks sularaha sisse sularaha välja.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame siia, siis
Õpetaja: Ega need Spaced, mis on Meil siin tag ide vahel ja veerajavahetused. Ega see ei ole ju Kood, kood. Ei, ütle, et siin on reavahetus.
Õpetaja: Mis me peame tegema Siin peab midagi. Midagi Peab siin selles ee viimases tulbas tegema. Teistmoodi. Mis mõtteid on?
Õpetaja: Kuidas?
Õpetaja: Nooh, kui sa tahad mingit pr I teha, siis see tegelikult on nagu reavahetus. Siis oleks Css oleks.
Õpetaja: Ei,
Õpetaja: ee, Me Ei, tee niukest asja. See ei ole tekst, kus me ütleme, et viska reavahetus, vaid mõtleme natuke teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: No tabel tabeli sees oleks ka võimalus, aga ei tahaks teha. Mõtleme veel natuke lihtsamalt. Võtame siis. Meil on vaja teksti. Aga niimoodi. Et iga tekst on puues lõigus, No nüüd ma rohkem vihjeid ei anna. Ta on nagu vahe eelmisega.
Õpetaja: See on meie mängumaa. Me kirjutame Html. I vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Palun ei, No seda juba pakuti. Me ei taha seda teha. Saaks teha nagu kindlat mitte.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha. Ee, me kirjutame Html koodi,
Õpetaja: kirjutame Html Koodi. Ja meil on hetkel vaja saada sellist tulemust, et iga tekst on selles mõttes ju eraldi lõik. Vaata, et ee, hoitakse vahet eelmise lõiguga. Nagu ma põhimõtteliselt tellin selle välja teil praegu.
Õpetaja: Mis saate meil elemente? Te teate hakake rääkima Just tekstiga. Midagi. Teksti kuvamine, Mis elemente Te teate
Õpetaja: näiteks mingi H. Üks. Ja kuidas pealkirjad?
Õpetaja: No okei, pealkirja. Mis see paragrahvid? Kuidas paragrahv käib,
Õpetaja: et sa kirjutad pika pika lõigu teksti Vaata ja mida ta teeb? Ta hoiab endast eelnevat asja nagu
Õpetaja: eelnev üleval üleval real ja lükkab ka alumist asja nagu erinevale.
Õpetaja: Noh, Aga Kas meil praegu polegi neid kaua? Või?
Õpetaja: Meil on ee vaja garanteeritult seda. Vaata, et iga tekst on eraldi lõik. Paragrahvi eraldatud teksti. Ee, vertikaalselt. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: vertikaalselt. Hoia, Siin on üks lõik. No on lugeda. Vaata, olete lugenud kellegi kirja, kes lihtsalt reavahetust ei oska. Kõik ühesõnaga Mingi erinevad asjad tahaks mingit kohta üle lugeda. Siis otsi seal. Vaata, ee, ei leia isegi silmaga kiirelt ülesse. Noh, aga kui me paneme siia.
Õpetaja: Me saame siia kirjutada mistahes elemente seal tulpa.
Õpetaja: Me paneme siia paragrahv, paneme sularaha
Õpetaja: sularaha sisse. Näiteks tublikad Tublikad ee. Välja
Õpetaja: ja võibolla Mina ei tea, maksed või midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole siis, kas tuleb niuke tulemus.
Õpetaja: Kui ma oleks kasutanud ka tive, siis ma pakun, et ka oleks saanud enam vähem ka sama analoogse tulemusi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas pöörduda, pr teeb, Html is ee, Aga see on vana kool. Sellepärast, et kui Me tahame teha mingisugust,
Õpetaja: et hoia kaks rida vahet.
Õpetaja: Paned Css, Lükka margin ja elementi. Me ei kasuta kindlalt koodis. Ja pealegi, ee, see Oleks nagu väga tobe. Vaata, et meil tegelikult see tulbas. Vaata, siin on teine asi ka. Te peate mõtlema ühele teisele asjale ka oletame,
Õpetaja: Oletame, et mina tahaksin teha niimoodi, et ee, sularaha sisse on. Roheline
Õpetaja: sularaha välja on punane ja maksed on kollane.
Õpetaja: Kui mul isegi oleks ma nüüd kommitin. Ära vaata. Sest ma ei viitsi. Ma panen. Mis asi see kümme
Õpetaja: ee.
Õpetaja: Working, Progress üks. Mida iganes comit,
Õpetaja: Ma ei pussi Seda ka praegu, siis tuleb ka. Keegi järgi tahab tulla praegu. Okei, no siis ma. Push in
Õpetaja: ee, kont. Ma ei mäleta, kuidas Bussil saab Shortcut I. Kas ta siin näitab seda Shift ka. Okei, Davai.
Õpetaja: Kus puss Pluss
Õpetaja: siis? Ta annab bussi pähe. Kiiremini, ta annab ussib kiiremini olemas. Võite järgi tulla. Senikaua ma räägin ja näitan. Mul on komiti, tegelane. See on
Õpetaja: kui mina tahaks praegult et ee, see oleks ühtepidi värvitud. See oleks teistpidi värvitud. See oleks kolmandat pidi värvitud. Näiteks
Õpetaja: kuidas ma saaksin seda teha? Ma panen. Siis teen mingid klassid Mis ee, värvivad vastavat värvi? Ja Paneksin igale ühele kirja, et sina, Sa
Õpetaja: punane sina saa. See on nii,
Õpetaja: kui mul oleks nüüd selline Lähenemine, mida siin korra nagu pakuti.
Õpetaja: Isegi kui.
Õpetaja: Isegi kui ma nüüd nende teksti vahel tekst lihtsalt ripendab, nagu tegelikult mitte ühegi teksti tekstilise selle tag I sees. Isegi kui ma paneksin siia selle Break I Näiteks Break. Siin
Õpetaja: Break siin. Noh, rohkem vist pole, vaja on ju? Ma saan selle tulemuse, aga nüüd on minu küsimus. Palun öelge mulle, kuidas ma saan värvida neid asju,
Õpetaja: kuidas ma saaks teid värvida, et Ühte värvi ja teist värvi. Ma ei saa lihtsalt siia teksti ette öelda, et klass
Õpetaja: klass võrdub mingi reed Noh, ei saa, on ju, Sest et ta ei ole kuskil ühegi tag I sees
Õpetaja: ei saa spetsiifiliselt seda teksti kuidagi kontrollida. Kui aga tema on nii, nagu oli Ennem palun. Väga,
Õpetaja: Ma saan programmiliselt nüüd teha. Mida iganes saate mõttest aru. Tekst peaks alati. Kas bänni sees olema, kui sa ei taha, et ta, kuidagi teistest asjadest eemal hoiab meile praegu need. Ee, ma vist. Ma pakun, et tiivid töötaksid sama hästi. Ma korra vaatan läbi,
Õpetaja: Ee, kui paragrahv
Õpetaja: Ma pakun etiv, hoiab ka ilusti. Ee, üksteisega vahet.
Õpetaja: Isegi parem. Ee, ta ei tee nagu mingisugust paragrahvi vahet, et ta tõmbas liiga laiali.
Õpetaja: Ma Isegi soovitaksin need Ee, ära muuta. Teed lihtsalt selle esimese tag I lihtsalt siniseks niimoodi. Ja kirjutad
Õpetaja: ja lähed siia Järgmise juurde klikiga.
Õpetaja: Div tabiga saab seda ka tegelikult panna Tv ja Tab Siis ta nagu fikseerib selle ära.
Õpetaja: Siis ei ole isegi veits Parem
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd Csiga. Ma saan ee mudida seda vahet, kui ma tahan hoida, et hoian natuke eemal üksteist. Parem kui paragrahv ütles isegi,
Õpetaja: Nii mis Nüüd Muidugi on vaja aru saada.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele et see on tegelikult ju meil sellest koodis.
Õpetaja: See osa siin Transaction types,
Õpetaja: Nüüd see asi ka peab Tulema Ju tegelikult dünaamiliselt olete nõus? Siin võib olla kaks See võib kolm. Siin võib üks olla. Jumal teab, Mitu objekti siin on? Ma küsin lihtsalt sellisena. Te võiksite selle ette joonistada, kui tahaksite. Aga ma küsin, et mitut ee mitut niiöelda seda Meil Hetkel on siin vaja mitut rida. Meil on vaja enda progemise jaoks
Õpetaja: üksainus sellepärast, et see asi tuleb ju mitmekordselt dünaamiliselt, on ju Nii,
Õpetaja: ma jätan ta praegu siiski ette niimoodi visuaalselt. See Ma ei viitsiks uut rida teha ja mingeid miljon. Noh, saaks ju tegelikult ka, Palun väga, kui tahaks. Nagu tõmban kogu selle kokku ja teen siin mitu. Oih, natuke niimoodi Päris ei saa.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma võtan niimoodi,
Õpetaja: No ma saaks ka niimoodi teha, kui ma tahaks saate mõttest aru, onju, et endale ette. Ee, kui see aitab mul mõelda, näiteks projekti, Ee, progemise käigus oleks sa täiesti nagu, okei, teha paar rida ette ja, et, noh, on, arusaam. Mis see on progemis hetkel kustutad ebavajaliku Staffi ära.
Õpetaja: Aga me juba praegu saaksime mõelda, et tegelikult meil on ainult vaja seda. Meil piisaks täiesti niimoodi,
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et see osa tuleb Dünaamiliselt, aga lihtsalt, et mitte ära unustada, et siin on massiiv, siis ma jätan ta praegu ette.
Õpetaja: Nii see osa on nüüd tehtud.
Õpetaja: No, Super Puper. Väga hea, No aga lähme siis edasi
Õpetaja: nüüd. Järgmine osa on siis see, et ee, tuleb teha
Õpetaja: tabeli täitmiseks Vajalik info saadetakse, Saadakse Back end teenusega ketappi. Session vastusest.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma küsin teilt. Ahah, Missioon on selline et meil on Back end teenus,
Õpetaja: mille me soovime hakata nüüd Aa, välja. Kutsume tarbima.
Õpetaja: Mis me nüüd siis teeme?
Õpetaja: Kuhu me läheme? Mida me teeme, Mis me kõige esimese sammuna teeme?
Õpetaja: Missioon, Ah, see ei ole kett. Kaks
Õpetaja: aktsiasse tuleb veel. Aga enne. Seda Vot jälle Piibel.
Õpetaja: Piibel.
Õpetaja: Meie piibel on sellepärast, et päriselus kogu see Asi genereeritakse meie back end server niiöelda koodibaasi pealt. Ta ei valeta. Ta räägib täpselt Kuidas meil on Contract,
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad Backendile saata Sõnumit, Kuidas, mismoodi? Mis Rajale? Mis Parameetrid, Mis ta tagasi annab? Mis vead ta viskab? Head ja tead. Ja,
Õpetaja: noh, suurepärane, väga, hea, väga Hea piibel.
Õpetaja: Paneme selle siia vasakule. Või? Noh, paremale, kuhu iganes. Te võite ka minu pealt vaadata, aga lihtsam,
Õpetaja: kui te võtate ka ise Editori lahti. Aa, minul on Aa, siin Link. Kuskil
Õpetaja: vanasti oli se Nii kaugele lähen. Ma tõstan ta ettepoole. Näed, see panen siia.
Õpetaja: Kas Teil on juba siukene. Pange ka. Vaata, mina Panen s väger editor sellepärast, et see on. Nagu online is pärast. Ta tahab, et teil on ka päris väger. Kaheksakümmend Kaheksakümmend. Tuleb jälle see sama asi lahti. Otsi üles õige teenus.
Õpetaja: Noh, kus on see teenus?
Õpetaja: Kõik on, no Kui Ei, mäleta, võib taaskist veel piiluda. On ju?
Õpetaja: Ah, Kurat,
Õpetaja: läks kinni. Teeme. Lahti ma panen selle kinni. Hoopis. Ee, Teeme ta Usta korra lahti, siis väge reditar. Nii mis veel öeldakse et meie teenus on
Õpetaja: Get Atm Locations Get Abi ja Atm Locations tagab
Õpetaja: tagastab pangaautomaatide Asukohtade infot. Tundub, et on, õige asi. Teeme lahti, paneme tema vasakule.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus see, et meil on kokku lepitud tava, kuidas meie Nagu Back end I teenuste vastu. Oma koodi kirjutame. Vaata, meil on nagu oma süsteem,
Õpetaja: millest ma siin räägin, et mul nüüd on küsimus, Me hakkame nüüd koodibaasis kuhugi koodi kirjutama. No minu küsimus. Et kuhu? Me? Mida hakkame kirjutama?
Õpetaja: Mis süsteem? Ja arhitektuur. Meil on sõnumite saatmise osas.
Õpetaja: Me tahame hoida selle väljasaatmise koha. Tahame hoida eraldi
Õpetaja: ja siis tema teda me kasutame. Me saame välja kutsuda. Me saame kogu aeg igalt poolt neid välja kutsuda. Ainult Tegele siis vastusega. Igal lehel. Nii nagu vaja on, on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, super.
Õpetaja: Ee. Selle hammustasime lahti.
Õpetaja: No Teeme lahti selle epi services.
Õpetaja: Hetkel on meil siin City Service Log in Service.
Õpetaja: Kumba võiks see teenus sobida
Õpetaja: Aga miks ta peaks City Sse selle trikiga Küsimus, Sõbrad
Õpetaja: ja see Domeen on seotud Location Itega Ad location Get One Location Get Locations et me, peame grupeerima neid asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidagi kokku. Siis me teeme lihtsalt uue New Noh, New ja. Ja
Õpetaja: kokku lepitud tava, et ainsuses on see subjekt Location Service
Õpetaja: Ad File loomulikult. Miks me muidu seda kirjutasime?
Õpetaja: Et seda asja oleks mujal võimalik näha. Siis siis ma kirjutan
Õpetaja: ja et seda komponenti oleks võimalik importida, Siis eeldab, et see on ee, eksportida võimalik.
Õpetaja: Nii eksport
Õpetaja: siia sisse siis saab kirjutada Aa meetodeid koodi, mida saab, käivitada, nüüd on meetodi nime vaja. Meil on ka kokku lepitud üks tava. Kuidas me seda hästi tehniliselt siin nimetame? Kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Keegi mäletab, kuidas Paneme selle meetodi nime kokku.
Õpetaja: Meetodi nimi peab ütlema täpselt, mida tema teeb.
Õpetaja: Ee, jaa,
Õpetaja: Zend. Siis vaatame Võtame selle Ketta on ju? Ja nüüd Vaatame urli. No seda ei pea ignoreerima. See on kõige lühine Zend kett
Õpetaja: Atm.
Õpetaja: Nii põhimõtteliselt peegeldab. Urli on ju?
Õpetaja: Mis ma nüüd siin kirjutan. See on meetodi nimi. Mis on meetodi struktuur. Mis nimele järgneb?
Õpetaja: Sulud mi? Mis on meetodil alati olemas. Ka peale sulge koodiplokk ehk Keha control, Shiftenter ja enter.
Õpetaja: Siin saab parameetreid panna, mis tuleb sisse ja nii edasi, on ju?
Õpetaja: Vaatame nüüd natuke seda teenust ka et Me saaks aru. Aa, meil on siis siin. Ee, Url on meil selline.
Õpetaja: Ta kasutab parameetreid Response juurde. Ei lähe sellepärast, et siin me responsiga Niikuinii midagi ei tee.
Õpetaja: Spons meid hetkel ei huvita. Meid huvitab ainult põhimõtteliselt see saatmise osa, mis on see kass siin praegu
Õpetaja: me Võime vaadata, mida ta hakkab tegema, et ta õnnelikul juhul tagastab Aa, niisuguse objekti.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui on midagi halvasti. Neli null, neli not found I leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati ja rohkem asju pole. Me võime seda piiluda, aga meid saatmise mõttes tegelikult üldse ei huvita praegu
Õpetaja: Meid huvitab ainult See asi ja meid huvitab, kas on parameetreid? Näitab, et siin on City Id peab. Tuleb kaasa, et sa muud moodi ei saa. Sa Pead andma nagu City Id.
Õpetaja: Näed, siis vastab palun väga siku pilli prisma. See tuli juba Stop light, onju nii? Okei, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Hakkame siia koodi kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Kuidas nüüd siis Kuidas tehniliselt on võimalik saata meie browser is sõnumit kuhugi kohta
Õpetaja: aktsias on ju aktsias. Taustal kasutab Fetch I Fetch Api. Me kasutame aktsias, Mis on selle peale ehitatud?
Õpetaja: Seal on See mõnus Ja Catš ja kõik need plokid on nagu mõnusalt ära tehtud.
Õpetaja: Mis on järgmine täht? Mis ma siia kirja panen?
Õpetaja: Et selles mõttes et selle, sõna võib ära kirjutada, on ju get Pakub niukest Ee, meetodit. Paneme selle meetodi
Õpetaja: nüüd. Ta näitab, meile mida on võimalik siia seda meetodit käivitades välja kutsudes. Temal on võimalik anda Mitu sisendit?
Õpetaja: Kaks, Kuidas te seda teate, Kooma? Lollikindel värk.
Õpetaja: Teistes keeltes ka, et Idrge on võimalik.
Õpetaja: Mis on erilist selle selle teisega? Selle Teisega Siin on kaks tükki, mis siin on, mida ma üritan viidata? Mis ee, mis see Küsimärk tähendas
Õpetaja: Valikuline võib, aga ei pea Nalla Peal võib jääda tühjaks, aga aga võib ka olla.
Õpetaja: No meie alustame ikka siit vasakult. Ee, vasakult öeldakse kõigepealt meile tüüp. Mis see tüüp on string.
Õpetaja: Tüüp on string.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et me peame kirjutama seda ringi. Nüüd Vihjeks. On siis see niiöelda parameetri nimi url. Siis Me teame, et siia peab käima mingi Url,
Õpetaja: mis meil peab siia käima, kui me vaatame oma piiblit. Jah, Täpselt see sama vorm.
Õpetaja: No Seal saab siit kopida. Niimoodi, Rõõmsalt.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas ta meil seal päris süsteemis toimib. Ehk siis paistab.
Õpetaja: Ee, vahel töötab, vahel ei Tööta
Õpetaja: nüüd. See on meil paigas, Aga nüüd on Parameeters ja City Id.
Õpetaja: Noh, idee järgi. Vaata, see on imeline parameeter, see saaks olla Niimoodi ma saaks sealt selle otsa ka keevitada ja öelda näiteks, et. Aa, mis selle nimi on? City Id.
Õpetaja: Ärge Tehke seda peate Ärge City Id.
Õpetaja: See on lõpptulemus. See on, kuidas sõnum läheb? City Id võrdub
Õpetaja: ja nüüd peab tulema mingi sisend. Vaata, onju, No ma saaks Plussiga panna siia mingi muutaja nime ja saaks nii ka teha, on ju? Aga kui neid on mitu ja nii edasi, siis ee, asi läheb koledaks ja tahad võibolla mingi eedressi midagi kaasa panna ja nii edasi, et niimoodi me ei taha teha.
Õpetaja: Me tahame selleks hoopis kasutada Point Figi.
Õpetaja: Mida konfiks sisse ootab? Tüübina objekti. Kuidas me saame siia kiirelt ühe uue objekti tekitada?
Õpetaja: Ei ole topelt, vaid lihtsalt lugudega saab ka seda parameetrit vajutada. Valida niimoodi Me saame siia panna parameetreid.
Õpetaja: Näete, nüüd, ta vastab täpselt. Sellele. Get Ket Url, Url,
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin Golfi Objektis saab olla erinevaid. Mis on siin erinevad omadused, mis siia objekti sobivad? Mis meid huvitab?
Õpetaja: Vasakul pool on ju vihje olemas. Piibel,
Õpetaja: mida Ma tahan sealt valida. Mis bloki?
Õpetaja: Aa, params. No, vasakul pool on ju parameeter. No siis Meil peab ka olema params see Params Tähendab,
Õpetaja: saab olla mitu. No aga siis on vaja kuidagi ulatust defineerida.
Õpetaja: Sellele parem sellele. Kuidas me seda ulatust defineerime.
Õpetaja: Ma saaks üle mitme koodirea kirjutada. No kuidas ma saan loo? Veidi?
Õpetaja: Jah, samamoodi
Õpetaja: kui mingi asi on mitmuses. Kuidagi peab skopi Panema. Kas on sulud või loogilised suled? Mõnes kohas võib olla erinevalt. Ta pani mingi sisendi. Mis ta sealt alt pakkus? Juba Ei, taha. Seda
Õpetaja: on niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No mis ma nüüd siia kirjutan. Siin On mingid parameetrid või mis? Siin ütleb, mis parameeter peab olema.
Õpetaja: City Id. Siis kirjutad käsitsi. Copy Based. Vahet pole, kui on keeruline, siis pigem Copy based Id.
Õpetaja: Kool on ju? Nüüd on tal vaja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on vaja mingit väärtust nii,
Õpetaja: noh, okei, no me Võime nulli panna. Korra siia, Vaata null. Niimoodi. Miks niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Aga.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga mina tahan. Ühel hetkel saate sõnumi. Hoopis ikkagi üks ja või kaks.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tahangi nulli Vahet. Pole me ju koodi. Ei saa öelda, et palun väga
Õpetaja: kogu aeg, lihtsalt too kõik ära no kui See oleks mu päris soov. Jah, ma saaks seda teha, Aga ma ju soovin, et see tuleb dünaamiliselt
Õpetaja: vaid nagu keegi tagant ütles, et Siis peaks.
Õpetaja: No tühjaks ei saa. Jätta.
Õpetaja: Tühjaks ei saa jätta. Pigem siia. Peabki tulema ju sisu samamoodi. Kujutage ette täpselt seda niimoodi, et Te tahate seda mingit sõnumit käivitada siit svägerist ja see töötab. Proovid testid, Vaatad oma päris back. Endist tuleb vastus ja nii edasi, on ju nii, Aga siis on see asi, et sa tahad seda, et.
Õpetaja: Kuule, aga halloo, nagu, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: kuidas siis see saab dünaamiliselt tulla,
Õpetaja: See meetod ei tea oma välisest elust tööd ega mütsi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Noh, okei.
Õpetaja: City Id on City Id.
Õpetaja: Mis ta siin? Mis see punane Joon tähendab, mis talle ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Ei, topelt. Loogilised sulud on Ainult siis, kui kirjutame templateist. Tagide vahel asuvat. Ee, mingit tekstielementi,
Õpetaja: näiteks Heeder Või H. Üks või paragrahv. Või isegi vahet pole. Aa, seal. Soovime öelda, et see ei ole tekst, vaid see on muutuja,
Õpetaja: see see Vastus on siin nagu õige. Vaata, aga praegu on, nagu et ta nagu ütleb, et sa räägid nagu mingisugusest muutujast,
Õpetaja: mis ei ole siin kuidagi ära defineeritud selles meetodis Pigem planeerimased.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me defineerime This viitaks sellele, et siin on mingi datablokk
Õpetaja: ja siin on mingi muutaja, No Siin ei ole mingit datablokki. Meil on vaates kuskil tatablokk,
Õpetaja: Aga mõte on õige. Nagu et kuskilt peab see sisu tulema,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd Ma Räägin juba miljonit korda. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui me teeme mingisuguse meetodi. Ta ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi. Kui sa soovid sellele meetodile mingit informatsiooni. Mingit informatsiooni soovid kasutada, siis sa pead
Õpetaja: muud sa veel Täpsemalt.
Õpetaja: Mitte muutuja.
Õpetaja: Silt. Aga nüüd, mis silt? Eriline silt.
Õpetaja: Parameeter. See Meetod peab olema korduvkasutatav. Seda peab saama igatepidi uuesti kasutada. Isegi kui me ostame It ühe korra, See meetod ei tea oma välisest tööd Ega mütsi. Ta ei tea midagi. Atms viust.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tea mitte ööd ega mütsi sellest. Atms View St. Kui seal Atmsi Views on Mingisugune informatsioon. Mis siin selle tegevuse käigus on vajalik.
Õpetaja: Siis Me peame ehitama selle nimelise koodiploki niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et ta on võimeline võtma vastu mingit informatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me taha soovime nüüd siin koodiplokis sellega informatsiooniga toimetada, siis me siin all on vaja mingisugust sildikese nime.
Õpetaja: Meetod nime. Jah, Mm, ma ei tea, mis sa mõtlesid selle all.
Õpetaja: Kas me soovime mingit infot siia alla siia meetodisse kaasa anda? Tegevuseks
Õpetaja: Soovime Mis infot Me soovime siia kaasa anda.
Õpetaja: City Id. Siis me mõtlemegi. Näed, teeme selle meetodi selliselt, et tema võtab sisse Parameetri City Id. Me loome siia sildikese,
Õpetaja: kui siin, Kui minul oleks, Ma teen natuke lihtsamat. Oletame, et see on mingi. Ma ei tea, ee mingi nime lisamine süsteemi
Õpetaja: Kui mina soovin ee, süsteemi lisada mingisugust uut Ee first name. I, vaata onju. Mina tahan seda meetodit käivitada. Andeks, sisendiks jutumärgid rain näiteks
Õpetaja: mõttes, et seda meetodit on võimalik käivitada
Õpetaja: mingisuguse infoga, siis mul peab siin olema mingi silt, et kui sina käivitad seda meetodit,
Õpetaja: viskad mingi Info siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Positsioonil üks siis mina. Ütlen, et Okei, Las olla seal sees.
Õpetaja: Niukene silt nimega City Id.
Õpetaja: Kui Ma tahan midagi rohkemat siia panna, siis ma panen koma ja mõtlen veel mingi sildi
Õpetaja: ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Seda meetodit oleks hetkel võimalik käivitada niimoodi, et see on võimalik anda kolm objekti põhimõtteliselt kaasa kolm infot.
Õpetaja: Kas ta on mingi mittekiiline objekt? Kas ta on lihtsalt ee Niukene primitiivne number, või mis Iganes
Õpetaja: see ei mängi rolli, siis mul on siin koodis võimalik
Õpetaja: nende infode ja andmetega nagu midagi teha,
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan, et ole hea, Ee, käivita see sõnumi saatmine Niimoodi, et City Id on kaks, Siis ma käivitangi selle meetodi niimoodi. Ma kutsun ta välja niimoodi. Et selles Esimeses kohas tuleb number kaks lihtsalt antakse kaasa ja see kukub lihtsalt siia Ja see seotakse selle
Õpetaja: muuta nimega. Ja nüüd ma saan seda siit kasutada. City Id.
Õpetaja: Näete, läks valgeks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Mul on võimekus. See meetod ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi. See ongi progemine, See on nii lihtne. Sul on meetod. Sul on parameetrid. Ta teeb midagi.
Õpetaja: Ta tagastab vahel midagi, kui on vaja. Ja kõik kõik b Nimeline kood,
Õpetaja: Mis nimi? Ütle, mida ta teeb progese ära, et ta seda teeb
Õpetaja: ja arvesta sellega. Vaata, et kui sul on vaja seal Tegevustes käigus, Mingisuguseid andmeid, Mingit infot
Õpetaja: siis sa pead selle nimelise koodilõigu selliselt defineerima, et sinna on võimalik andmeid kaasa panna. Kuidas seda me Osa Teeme andmekaasa panemist parameetritega
Õpetaja: parameetritega. Vaadake uuesti seda õppematerjali. Meetodi Struktuur
Õpetaja: Vaadake uuesti seda õppematerjali me meetodi struktuur. Vaadake Nüüd sealt alt
Õpetaja: Noh, Tahaks aega kulutada, aga kulutame siis korra veel toks.
Õpetaja: Ee, tear imiterials
Õpetaja: ja ava ja ava skrip meetodid. Noh, vaatame seda uuesti.
Õpetaja: Mis on Meetod, koot, struktuur, nähtavus, tagastustüüp, nimi, Parameetreid. Vaatame siin. Iga osa selgitab lahti, mille jaoks on vajalik
Õpetaja: parameetrid. Sisendid koos tüüpidega.
Õpetaja: Tagastustüüp tagastustüüp Parameetrid. Miks on vaja? Parameetrid on meetodi koostisosad.
Õpetaja: Annad meetodile andmed, millega ta töötab.
Õpetaja: Noh, Easy. Beasy Element Squizy
Õpetaja: Ee ülejäänud jama kustutame siit ära Ei, ole vaja mulle rohkem andmeid kui City Id ja kõik
Õpetaja: nüüd, mis siin. Miks see kollane joon on Sellel? Ketil
Õpetaja: See on see Telefoni värk. Vaata, et tõmbad raati. Ma annan sulle toru,
Õpetaja: Aga see on nagu see, et. Noh, aga keegi siin midagi ei tee sellega, Jah,
Õpetaja: kui teeks pikalt seda, siis oleks see, et kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi, mis midagi tagastab ja sa soovid selle infoga edasi midagi teha. No Back end ju tagastab Infot, millega me soovime midagi edasi teha. Me soovime sellest tabelit teha.
Õpetaja: Siis pane see muutusse, isegi Kui teeks praegu Alguses teeks vähemalt selle sammu Ära Vaata, Näiteks kehtib rohkem nagu javas. Ee, response.
Õpetaja: No ma paneks isegi promise
Õpetaja: promis.
Õpetaja: Pane See muutujasse. Kuulame seda laulu ka.
Õpetaja: Ta tagastab ta. Ta annab telefoni põhimõtteliselt sulle.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa praegu oleksid nüüd siin, siis sa vaataksid, et. Oi, aga mul on. Noh, siin on vastavalt kellene. Näitab, kellele Näita. Vaata, see on idea. Vaata, see ei ole koodi osa, saate aru see siin ei ole. Ma ei saa klikkida seda kuidagi idea. Lihtsalt näitab, et mis tüüpi objekt siin taga põhimõtteliselt on,
Õpetaja: et kui sa vähemalt siin seisaksid. Siis sul oleks võibolla millestki nagu rääkida,
Õpetaja: et nagu oleksid siin. Et mis ma nüüd edasi teen, aga mul on Siuks muutuja mitte midagi temaga ei tee. Tema elab ja sureb siin. No siis võiks niimoodi pikalt kirjutada. Saaks panna retöör. Aa, ma pean selle tagastama Ju see, kes selle välja kutsub, kasutab seda
Õpetaja: tema. Muidugi ütleb, et sa lood muutuja siin. Ta ütleb, et sa lood muutuja Järgmisel reaalse juba Returnil nagu. Miks ta nagu ütleb, et tee see Niimoodi Return. I nagu inline. Pane see kohe.
Õpetaja: Pane kohe see muutuja. Otse return. Ile, põmm. Ehk siis ainuke. Asi, mis ta tegelikult tegi, oli see, et pani return I siia ette.
Õpetaja: See kettahindis märk, Sa Kutsud midagi välja sa mitte kunagi midagi sellega ei tee. Nüüd ta näeb, et sa teed midagi.
Õpetaja: Sa tagastad selle siit meetodist, Sellega tehakse midagi.
Õpetaja: Sest kui seda pole, siis ta küsib. Nagu. Mis sa siis kutsud mind? Anna mulle midagi, mina näen vaeva ja annan sulle midagi,
Õpetaja: Sina Ei, võta seda vastu ja ei tee sellega midagi. See on see kollane joon seal. Sa ei tee mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: nagu seda jaava hakkab ka meile märku andma. Kui sa ee, kutsud välja mingi meetodi, mis midagi tagastab,
Õpetaja: ja siis sa ei tee sellega mitte midagi. See on nagu kutsud mind välja. Kutsu mind välja. See on nagu see, et nagu Deedile Vaata, kutsud kellegi välja. Plaan on see, et nagu ma Ei, tea, lähme kuskile midagi Sööma Helistad, et kuule saame. Saame nagu kokku ja ei tulegi nagu vastu. Ei saagi kokku. Vaata, teine Tuleb niisama välja.
Õpetaja: No mis siis kutsud? Ära kutsu, kui sa ei taha minuga välja minna.
Õpetaja: Nii väikene one. Nüüd meil on see meetod olemas. Mida see hall siin tähistab,
Õpetaja: et seda keegi hetkel ei ei kasuta. Nagu on ju keegi mind? Ei, mul on olemas niukene nimeline koodilõik. Aga mind ei ole kuskil veel Kasutavad. Väga tore.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ongi see, et nüüd peame siis vaatama, et mismoodi siis seda kasutama peab, Onju?
Õpetaja: Meile oli öeldud, et Tabel täidetakse automaatselt leheküljele maandudes
Õpetaja: Tabeli täitmiseks vajalik info saadet Saadakse Back and teenusega bla bla, bla kaasa antakse Ee, City Id parameeter. Esialgu antakse selle väärtus nullile.
Õpetaja: Okei, Davai.
Õpetaja: Ee, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Lähme siis, Kui me läheme, lähme vaatame siis tagasi ja Hakkame siis mõtlema, mis tegema peab.
Õpetaja: Siin on hea koht ja paus ka. Ma teen selle komitee bussi ka ära. Teeme oma, et nagu uut asja sellega. Nüüd läheb aega.
Õpetaja: Teeme väikse värskenduse ja siis juba.
Õpetaja: Ee. Siis juba hakkame pusima selle kallal.
Õpetaja: Palun
Õpetaja: Selle sellepärast, et oota Minu ekraanil näitas nagu vihjena. Vaata, sa kirjutasid selle sisse ja sa pead. Selle See pool on ka. Mis sul seal kirjaleb, seda nagu ei saa olla.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd on juba parem.
Õpetaja: Aa, miks ta sulle viskas? Ja mul. See. No vot sellepärast ongi kõik katki, nüüd on Juba parem.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei. Puhta vist,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, see on. Jah. Ee. Kellele kellele näita saavad lokaalsete sead seadetele. Mul on mõndades kohtades maha keeratud mõnes kohas, ta nagu näitab. Vaata, jah, aga see on klassikaline asi, mis juhtub igal kursusel. Kellelgi Vaata, on ka see, et visuaalse, Tundub, et see on osa koodist, aga tegelikult ei ole.
Õpetaja: Samas on Jumala Huvitav on see, et kui sa lähed siukse asjaga pusima, nagu
Õpetaja: Siis siis kaob see nägemus. Mis sa räägid, tervikpilt kaob ära Nagu, et see.
Õpetaja: Aga kui sul, Kui sul on natukene nagu raske, vaata Pigem teind seda, et ma jätan selle koodi. Kas ta olla? Ja siis ma pigem vaatangi. Siis tuleme järgi jälle. Vaata, võibolla nagu natukene vaatab. Meil tuleb niikuinii mingi loomulikult kohta. Siis ei lähe uuesti proovida, Onju,
Õpetaja: et ee, proovi nagu kaasas püsida ja kui tunned, et jääb, Sul on nagu valik, igal juhul,
Õpetaja: Aga tegelikult pean ka
Õpetaja: võibolla selgema
Õpetaja: läbi töötanud, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma tahan,
Õpetaja: et seda saate sellega käida.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: jah,
Õpetaja: need peavad oma see pildid, et august
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: võib olla.
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: jah, kindlasti.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: koju
Õpetaja: et ongi, see.
Õpetaja: Tere, Failist isiklikult, rääkida
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: otse.
Õpetaja: Jah, kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Tere,
Õpetaja: Jah, see kultuur.
Õpetaja: Seda tööd selle koju
Õpetaja: töötada.
Õpetaja: Hea olla,
Õpetaja: aitäh.
Õpetaja: Võimalikult.
Õpetaja: Aitäh.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ilus See juhtus ka teie poolt numbri.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see joosta.
Õpetaja: Võiks seda teha. Rekord jäi jälle. Peale Jah,
Õpetaja: on üldse record. Jumal tänatud söögi,
Õpetaja: aga seda vist ei tasu teha, onju? Pigem tasub. Tasub nagu sinuga selles ühes failis olla ja mõelda ise, mis? Nagu järgmisena tuleb, Sest kohta materjal on nagu Väike väga palju
Õpetaja: Näiteks need eelmised failid, mida me oleme teinud lõppkokkuvõttes. See struktuur on nagu, väga sarnane. Lihtsalt peab väikseid muutusi tegema
Õpetaja: jaa muidugi. Aa, ei, no ma ei tahagi seda. Vaata, siin on. Tegelikult on üldse. Ma tahan klassis. Vaata, need inimesed, kes väga ei oska, Vaata, neid asju peavad mõtlema, Vaata, onju? Ma mõtlen nagu eelkõige, Kui ma küsin üldse, midagi. Ee,
Õpetaja: parem on see kui keegi ei vaata, Vaata, nagu üldse nagu. Jah, absoluutselt, et, ee, Noh, mustriga. Vaata, onju, Ee, et et ee, pigem on hea. Üldse. Vaata, klassiruumis ongi niimoodi Noh, Kui iga inimene peab, korras mõtleb. Vaata, onju? Ta isegi ei tea seda vastust.
Õpetaja: Aga see, et ta juba nagu mõtleb, vaata, ja Kõik vastused, mis tulevad. Ee, on enda pakutud. Vaata, siis see kinnistub. Nagu. Vaata, ka lõpuks, et kui keegi pakub nagu. Vaata, nagu oma Nagu teadmiste järgi juba mingisuguseid õigeid vastuseid. Siis talle jääb nagu meelde. Vaata, aga, noh, kõigile peab jääma võimalus ka nagu seda. Noh, korra. Nagu mõelda. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, sest et iga kord, kui välja ei mõtle, vaata, siis ma räägin sellest õigest vastusest, siis see kuidagi hakkab niimoodi Aja jooksul nagu kinnistuma niimoodi ja ja et ee. Ja ei, absoluutselt. Ja ma ütlen ka pigem pigem mingi hetk on juba see ka, Vaata, kui ma näen nagu need targemad teavad neid vastuseid, siis ma juba hakkan juba asju ütlema. Vaata, et, Ee, ära sina vasta, vaata, Et, noh,
Õpetaja: ee. Et teised veel peaksid mõtlema.
Õpetaja: Ee, ütle korra uuesti palun. Neid ei saa vaadata. Need ei saa, Ja need on need on minu. Need on minu, Nagu selles. Ee, Private Private kontol, et ma ei saa neid kuidagi nagu sinna teise kohta nagu niimoodi kanda, Nagu
Õpetaja: ilma et see lõhuks. Ära vaata neid, Car Portfelli Projekte Põhimõtteliselt, aga põhimõtteliselt. Ega see ei olegi vajalik. Vaata, et me nigu niikuinii Ainult õpime. Läheme nende järgi. Ee, et, ee as we go along.
Õpetaja: Ma muidugi Pdfidena saaksin neid jagada niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, sest et Pdf saab teha.
Õpetaja: No, päris suur klubu.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, aa, kuulge. Aga ma ei vaadanud kella. Te ei vastata kella,
Õpetaja: et viiskümmend peaks olema poolset tagasi niimoodi. Jah, viimane
Õpetaja: võimalus. Davai. Aa, meil võimalus on
Õpetaja: kolme tunni kohta. Siit saab mingi per minut. Saab välja juba arvutada.
Õpetaja: Keskmiselt siis null Koma. Kaheksa.
Õpetaja: No näed, tuleb neid Ilmselt Seal on tegelikult mingeid muid asju ka Tegelikult, mida ei pane tähele.
Õpetaja: Üks sõna, mis ma tean, Mis mul on näiteks vaata hästi tihti. Kui inimesega suhtled, siis Kuidagi see. Vaata, tuleb nagu, ee, väga kuidagi lihtsalt üle huulte, ja siis tegelikult on. See. Hakkad mõtlema, mida on nagu vaadata nendes kohtades. Nagu et see ei ole üldse täielik. Nagu Kas siis mõttekoht, side, sõna Mida iganes, kuidas seda defineerida.
Õpetaja: Aga vaata. Ja siis hakkad midagi ütlema. Nagu, et sõna otseses mõttes. Mida sa siis ütled inimeselt vaata,
Õpetaja: ja Neid on veel Ja tegelikult Aa.
Õpetaja: Niukseid asju on võimalik välja koolitada. Ma olen tähele pannud kuidas mõned niiöelda kõrgema taseme
Õpetaja: ee, poliitikud esinejad suudavad ee ikkagi rääkida. Väga hästi. Ma ei räägi seda kui nad loevad kuskilt maha midagi, vaid nagu sõna, otseses mõttes räägivad, et neil ei ole tegelikult parasiitsõnu.
Õpetaja: Neil ei ole neid eesid Seda on võimalik ee välja juurida.
Õpetaja: Peksa palju rääkima. Seda hääl ära. Nagu ühesõnaga, siis Ükskord
Õpetaja: logopeed ja kliinikusse korra, et sul ei ole nagu tegelikult mingi kõri või mingi häälimise Või noh, selle hääl, Ta läks logopeedi juurde, Tal määrati harjutused, et ta kasutab oma häälepaelast Ja siis ta pidi mingit puhumise ja mullitamise ja mingeid siukseid harjutusi tegema. Korras
Õpetaja: ongi nii Logopeed Ainult siukse asja juures. Mõtled, et sul on mingisugune.
Õpetaja: Vot ongi see, et meil on nagu mingid tööriistad, mida võibolla kasutad valesti, Ise Ei teagi. Vaata seda. Ee, mul on siin ka paar. Mul on eelmine kursus. Läks täiesti ära, et tegime siin, sosistades ka asju vaata, Et, ee,
Õpetaja: et läks täitsa niimoodi ära. Et. Ee, tõesti. Aga seal. Võibolla oli nagu mingi külmetushaigus ka. Mis natukene mängis rolli? Kuulge, aga Panen sulle ukse kinni ee. Kui, sealt keegi veel on tulemas küll. Nad panevad selle pärast ka see. Võib olla märku et, me nagu Hakkame pihta.
Õpetaja: Ee, ee, rekordim. Ah, rekordib. Niikuinii vist on see mummu Seal vist. Ee kuskil olemas.
Õpetaja: Ma teen nüüd siis ee Screenshare I tagasi
Õpetaja: Ja mis? Me leppisime kokku, et teeme siis selle lahti.
Õpetaja: Ja, noh, ma võin kõrvale teha. See ei ole vaja teil lahti teha, Aga ma teen siis kõrvale selle Location service, et meil on meeles,
Õpetaja: et neil on selline teenus, mida me tahame kasutada.
Õpetaja: No nüüd, mistahes tegevusega. Aa, on ikka niimoodi, et me peame nii, nagu me tegime, et linnaandmed tuuakse ära.
Õpetaja: Me peame tegema juurde ühe meetodi täpselt samamoodi, Nagu Siin Before kutsutakse. Välja Too linnaandmed ära. Peab olema sama asi, et too ära need andmed.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on nüüd siin koha jälle vaja meetodit, et me ei hakka kirjutama siia, et kutsu välja vaid me teeme siia eraldi meetodi
Õpetaja: Ee, juurde.
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla siis paneme siis kohe siia.
Õpetaja: Järjekorda võiks ka veits kuidagi panna. Set Selected City It. Noh, pärast tõstab neid järjekorda. Paneme lihtsalt praegu siia, mis võiks olla Selle Uue meetodi nimi
Õpetaja: kõige lühemalt saaks panna. Võibolla hästi natuke pikemalt saaks panna, aga kuna meil ei ole mingeid muid Location eid siin meie selles infosüsteemis. Noh, mis? Et Vaata, millal on vaja. Nagu täpsem on see, et kui sul on mingeid sarnaseid asju,
Õpetaja: meil on ainsad Location Id siin süsteemis Aa, Atm Location Id. Siis võiks panna kõige lähemalt Get Locations.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: Get Locations,
Õpetaja: Mis edasi?
Õpetaja: No seda nüüd on võimalik käivitada. Esiteks, keegi seda ei käivita, on nii? Aga kus? See millal või kus see peaks käivituma?
Õpetaja: Tabel täidetakse automaatselt leheküljele maandudes ee Selle sõnumi abil on ju
Õpetaja: Before. Mount peaks hakkama seda käivitama. Nii nagu on Get Cities võiks olla Get Locations nii nagu Before kutsub välja Get Cities, siis siin. Tahame öelda, et kutsuge ta välja
Õpetaja: kohe lehele saabudes. Get Locations Kaks sõnumit. Peab minema Deed Locations.
Õpetaja: No nüüd vähemalt kui siia klikkida. Peale kontrolli, kas me näeme, et. Noh, see on siin sinine. Keegi teda tahab Ja kasutab ka,
Õpetaja: mis nüüd edasi Käivitatakse meetod Get locations. Nüüd on aeg siis seda implementeerida, et Noh, see peab tulema lahendus
Õpetaja: ja ma kõigepealt viitan sellele failile,
Õpetaja: et see, et seda me ei näe. Vaata, on ju Aga idee järgi. See Fail on olemas Location Service ja seal sees on meetod, mida me Tahame käivitada
Õpetaja: siis mis need suured tähed on?
Õpetaja: Ls Nüüd peab natuke vaatama. Log in service on ka, onju, et tuleb valida. Ikka see õige asi.
Õpetaja: See tegi see ülesse impordi nii nagu ikka
Õpetaja: Nüüd on. Viide sellele failile. Noh, teen siit lahti. Kõrvalt Näed, läheb siia, kohta on ju?
Õpetaja: On selle failiga seotud. Okei, Location Service.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see nüüd. See. Ee. Fail on mul siin kättesaadav objekti kujul.
Õpetaja: Võtan käivitada sealt meetodeid. Kuidas saab siis käivitada meetodeid
Õpetaja: ja punkti abil? Näete, Ida markeerib meil koodilõigude ära. Ka et ta räägib Siin erinevatest asjadest M on Nagu methods.
Õpetaja: Mingi meetod.
Õpetaja: Nüüd oleme selle meetodi juures. Siis siin võiks vaadata Control Bga, et mida ta sisse ootab.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: mis sa mõtled siin kohal on
Õpetaja: Miks loogilised sul on? Me ei kirjuta loogilises sulgusid ainult. Template Ja ainult siis, kui me oleme tagide vahel,
Õpetaja: peab ikka neid reegleid tegema. Ka õpetused. Vaata, et see kipub kuidagi minema. Aga tegelema sellega. Võibolla hiljem.
Õpetaja: Loogiliselt. Sul üldse läheb, mis siia, peab ühel Või teisel viisil minema.
Õpetaja: Okei, City Id peab minema.
Õpetaja: Mis see City Id on? Mida?
Õpetaja: Hint. On ju, et see kas võib öelda niimoodi, et see peab ühel või teisel viisil minema. Mingi number.
Õpetaja: Aga kas on niimoodi, et siin öeldakse, et esialgu kui me, ee niiöelda laeme, Siis ta väärtus peab olema null. Aga pärast peab olema hoopis see, mis on ee, valitud linn on ju.
Õpetaja: No kui me praegu mõtleme Ja vaatame natukene.
Õpetaja: Isegi See mis visuaalis on Siis mis siia võiks sobida ideaalselt.
Õpetaja: No jaa, aga
Õpetaja: me. Kuidas me pärast siis käivitame seda, et on mingi muu number. Nagu see kuidagi. Dünaamiliselt ju muutub. On ju, et vastavalt vajadusele.
Õpetaja: Praegult. Ta peaks olema null pärast. Ta peab olema hoopis kolm. No ma ei saa seda koodina siia sisse kirjutada. Peab viitama justkui mingisugusele
Õpetaja: nii. Ja kui me nüüd on juba õigel teel, et keegi juba ütleb, et Data
Õpetaja: peaks midagi olema. Mingi muutuja. Nüüd on küsimused selles, et
Õpetaja: mis ma ütlen, mis ma siia kirjutan,
Õpetaja: Data ei saa kirjutada sellepärast, et Data ei ole siin. Ei tähenda midagi. Küll. Tähendab ta data blokist Midagi
Õpetaja: Citys. Punkt City Id, aga See on ju massiiv. See on ju see. Vaata, Get City. See on. Siin on Massiivlinnadest
Õpetaja: ja Citys Punkt City Id does not comput Anyway, Sest, et see pole objekt, vaid see on massiivne.
Õpetaja: Kui sa kirjutatakse Cities nurkäalised või need kantsulud. Element, null, punkt, City Id. No See oleks midagi, aga see on ju massiiv. Ju? Ma ei saa ju viidata suvaliselt mingisugusele X Elemendile. Ma isegi ei tea, palju siin Element Siin isegi ei pruugi midagi tulla. Backendist. Võibolla tuleb tühi massiiv.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted veel on? Ahhaa,
Õpetaja: kas vastab tõele, et meil on juba Data blokis olemas. Aa, vaikimisi. Kui komponent laetakse. Mis on tema väike väärtus
Õpetaja: null? Ja kas tegime ju niimoodi, et kui Dropdownist midagi valid, Siis see tuleb siia. Ee, uus väärtus.
Õpetaja: Näete, selle sama meetodiga saab uue väärtuse. Isegi alert tuleb praegu. On ju, et siin sees ongi kogu aeg põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Selected Option, onju? Alguses on ta null. See voolab sinna alla. Kui see muutub, siis see muutub.
Õpetaja: Ja kas võib öeldagi, et see ongi ju siis see et too ära kõik linnad või too ära. Tallinna
Õpetaja: Location Id on nii?
Õpetaja: Siis mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Viis punkt Selected City Id Nüüd tuleb siia sisse Päris väärtus, vastavalt
Õpetaja: nüüd. See on sõnumi saatmine. Selle paneme nüüd, kinni, Mis nüüd järgneb tema. Noh, me näeme ju. Vaata, Nüüd saab klikki ta lahti. Niimoodi ka. On ju, et me näeme, et see asi return Ib promiss It.
Õpetaja: See meetod saab promise objekti
Õpetaja: promiss. Objektil on olemas erilised meetodid, mis oskavad selle promissiga toimetada. See on see telefon,
Õpetaja: Kas keegi vastab Millal ja mis ta sulle ütleb?
Õpetaja: Mis ma nüüd siin saan Teha selle, kui sellega saab kogu see asi ühel või teisel viisil, rehkendub Promiss objektiks.
Õpetaja: Ma saan käivitada tema küljest mingisuguseid meetodeid, Mis meetodeid võiks käivitada?
Õpetaja: Mida tema ise tegelikult käivitab?
Õpetaja: Ta oskab käivitada Ten meetodit, kui tuleb midagi hästi.
Õpetaja: See niimoodi üksteisest Ta oskab käivitada, kui midagi elab halvasti. Ta oskab käivitada Final It, mille ta käivitab nii või naa,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb jälle see sama Muster
Õpetaja: If. See on ka enne nagu If Wen Else.
Õpetaja: Ja see on nagu finali nagu lõpus. Käivit ta nii või naa.
Õpetaja: Kui me oskame niukse mudeli enda jaoks juba ära teha, siis ülejäänud on juba siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on meil juba pool tööd tehtud. Ütleme nii Nüüd ongi niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Millal Millal see blokk käivitakse? Millal see Den Block käivitub?
Õpetaja: Kuidas ei, ei, see blokk Ei Käivitu siis, kui said valiku tehtud.
Õpetaja: Siin on palju tehnilisem. Millal tehniliselt? Millal see blokk käivitub?
Õpetaja: Zenblock?
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb mingi kahesajaga algav staatus,
Õpetaja: Http. Sõnum läheb Httb protokolli kaudu mööda interneti teele. Tema ootab vastust, kui tuleb vastus. Kus on kakssada? Kakssada, üks, kakssada, kolm kakssada, neli. Whatever,
Õpetaja: siis tema jaoks on see positiivne olukord. Ja teine blokk käivitub.
Õpetaja: Millal see Catchblown käivitub?
Õpetaja: Kui on nelisada või viissada neljasajaga nelisada üks Nelisada, kaks, nelisada, kolm. Nelisada. Ise ka. Viissada. Viissada. Üks viissada kakskümmend.
Õpetaja: Kui on midagi mingi kaka on toimunud, käivitub see
Õpetaja: mis värk selle Final. Iga on, kuidas tema töötab.
Õpetaja: Tema käivitub siis, kui üks nendest on ära tehtud.
Õpetaja: Stenblock on käivitunud. Catchblock on käivitunud. Siis lõpus otsa Buraki käivitub see ka.
Õpetaja: Okei Alustame sellest tennist. Ikka Alati positiivsed asjad. Kõigepealt, onju, et Ee, nüüd siia sisse saab kirjutada, kui ise tahaks Kirjutada siia, et kõigepealt on vaja mingit muud nime.
Õpetaja: Error ei ole error. Sorry. Mulle meeldib siin kasutada response.
Õpetaja: Nüüd saab öelda, et hei. Siin on üks uus sildikene. See on nagu see, et ütleme, et siin meetodis saab panna parameetreid. Ee, First name. See on sildike?
Õpetaja: Siin on samamoodi. Vaata, me loome lihtsalt ühe sildikese. Ja nüüd me ütleme võrdusmärk ja noolekene et teeme mingid Action Id
Õpetaja: Nüüd see tehnoloogia ise.
Õpetaja: Kui kui tuleb mingi vastus, mis on kahesajaga algav staatus, siis tema paneb kogu vastuse, Paneb siia sisse. Kogu vastuse paneb kõik headerid, staatused, Staatus, tekstid, staatus, koodid, data ja nii edasi. Kõik kogu kupatus on ühe objektina Siin selle sees.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see asi siin on pildikene ja nüüd siit edaspidi. Peale seda toonekest me saame seda silti kasutada.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahaks üle mitme koodirea kirjutada, siis ma paneks siia koodiploki ja Muudkui kirjutaks, et nüüd ma ei tea Tee midagi,
Õpetaja: aga meie ei taha niimoodi teha. Me tahame hoopis, et me tahame selle responsiga tegeleda, Aga eraldi abimeetodis,
Õpetaja: et me ei risusta, et see see asi hakkaks siin mingi ridade mõttes Nagu mingi monstriks kasvama
Õpetaja: koodiread tulevad, millest midagi aru ei saa, siis ma tahaks öelda lihtsalt, et Davai. Me tegeleme
Õpetaja: selle õnneliku olukorraga, aga me tegeleme selle uues meetodis ja nüüd me Kasutame seda tööriista nagu enda kasuks ära, et me kirjutame koodi. Me kirjutame, et me kutsume välja abimeetodi, mida tegelikult me ei ole veel defineerinud,
Õpetaja: Aga intellige ise. Teeb meile selle ise ära nii öelda.
Õpetaja: Me tahame, öelda, et siin kuskil siis on meetod nimega.
Õpetaja: Noh, keegi mäletab Handle.
Õpetaja: Need on handel What Handle Get Locations Response.
Õpetaja: See on meetod.
Õpetaja: Jällegi, seda meetodit ei ole veel defineeritud. Nimelist Koodilõiku meil veel ei ole. Me kutsume välja meetodid, mida pole olemas
Õpetaja: Nüüd Selles see mõte ongi, et. Aga selles, kui sul on. Noh, kus see nüüd see Oli meil Siin Ee, taks. Taks, taks, taks.
Õpetaja: Võtame see. Jätan selle edaspidi lahti. Veel natukeseks.
Õpetaja: Teooria meteorias.
Õpetaja: Parameetreid. Miks on vaja parameetrid? On Meetris Koostisosad. Annad meetodile andmed, millega ta töötab?
Õpetaja: Annad meetodile andmed, millega ta töötab?
Õpetaja: No siin ongi. Sa kutsud välja Meetodi? Sa tahaksid talle anda mingisugused andmed. Mis on siin selle objekti sees, millega ta töötab.
Õpetaja: Siis me paneme siia sulud. Ütleme, et kutsu see meetod välja. Need Sulud peavad niikuinii olema Ja nüüd me ütleme, et kuuleme, kui me kutsume selle meetodi välja samamoodi nagu me siit kutsume, Vaata, et et ole Hea Location Services on meetod. Me anname talle andmed kaasa. Väärtuse null või üks või kaks
Õpetaja: siin samamoodi. Me tahame öelda et. Kuule, Aga anna need andmed kaasa. Selle jaoks see silt ongi.
Õpetaja: Selle jaoks. See silt ongi, et me siin saame öelda, et tead, me saame vastuse
Õpetaja: selle vastuse küljes. See on seotud selle sildiga. Siis tahame selle sildiga teha. Mingit action It.
Õpetaja: Siin ongi see, et kutsu välja meetod Ja anna andmed, andmed,
Õpetaja: parameetreid.
Õpetaja: Annad meetodil andmed, millega ta töötab. See meetod Nüüd ei tea oma välisest elust jälle nagu ööd ja mütsi, Jah, tal on ligipääs kõikidele asjadele, mille teistelgi meetoditele. Nendele asjadele on ligipääs kõikidele meetodidele. Aga tal ei ole ligipääsu rambist nagu, kuule, oo, Mul on. Nagu.
Õpetaja: Mul on. Nagu ma. Ma teeme selle meetodi ära. Vaata, onju? Ma teen korra selle meetodi ilma. Teie ärge tehke seda Teie juba vajutage praegult. Aa, siin kuskil selle oranži joone juures. Siin
Õpetaja: kollane pirn. Create Function tegi siia kuskile selle alla.
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla nii Palju võiks teha, et ee. Paneb see koma ka. Tõstab selle siia tagasi tema lähedusse.
Õpetaja: See meetod tuleks. Tegelikult on nii halb, vaata onju Tahaks nagu lugeda järjest Control Iksiga. Võtad selle siit ära ja tuled Tood selle meetodi alla
Õpetaja: Niimoodi saate mõttes aru, siis on ta nagu lähestikku teineteisele.
Õpetaja: Ma näen neid siit enamvähem, kui
Õpetaja: kui mina ei annaks seda objekti kaasa. Ja kui minul ei oleks siin selles meetodis niukest võimekust.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd mina tahan nagu heise vastus, mis? Ma sain internetist. Ma soovin temaga midagi teha
Õpetaja: siin Java Scriptis. Ma ei saa kuidagi teha niimoodi, et.
Õpetaja: Kuule, ma ei saa kirjutada praegu programmi, et Kuule programmi juhised. Kuule, ole hea, võta ee. Realt.
Õpetaja: Seitsekümmend Seitsekümmend muutuja.
Õpetaja: Panen Sulgudest Sildike, muutuja, objekti, smuuto ja Sildike Response objekti, andmed ja T.
Õpetaja: Midagi Xx. Mida Iganes ma ei saa öelda. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mul ei ole siin programmis võimalik. Või kui see meetod, ei tea ma välisest tööd. Ega ma üldse. Ma ei saa viidata sellele objektile. Siin ma ei Saa niukest asja pole siin Sellisest ei ole niukest võimalust, et ma saan mingi kohaliku muutu, et mis on mingi teise meetodi sees, tema elab ja sureb. Siin Ma ei saa kuidagi talle viidata.
Õpetaja: Kui ma soovin neid andmeid, siis ongi see, et ma pean tekitama, et okei, Seda meetodit on võimalik käivitada. Ma mõtlen siin välja mingisuguse sildikese response, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on võimalik niimoodi, et see meetod
Õpetaja: annab mulle kaasa Selle info, see sildike ja see sildike on selles mõttes eraldi sildikesed See sildikene elab ainult siin selle sulgude. Vahepeal.
Õpetaja: See sildikene elab alates Põhimõtteliselt selles kohas siin kuni siiani.
Õpetaja: Aga siin see sildikene saab olla seotud mingi objektiga selle objektiga, mis kaasa antakse Tegelikult siin silti anda. Siin Ma võin panna kirja nimeks
Õpetaja: Ja see töötab, sest et see lihtsalt on sildikene Siin selles skoobis Selles meetodi blokis objekt antakse üle, Mitte
Õpetaja: sildike, et see vahel algajatel on ju see mulje. Vaata, et nad peavad tingimata kattuma.
Õpetaja: Ei pea tingimata kattuma.
Õpetaja: Läheks keeruliseks kui Aa, Noh, võibolla ma tahangi nimetada seda asja siin selles kontekstis. Natuke teistmoodi
Õpetaja: siin. Juba täpsemalt. Näiteks siin hägusemalt.
Õpetaja: Näiteks, kui ma tahaksin seda,
Õpetaja: üldse, Ma võin ka tegelikult anda. Meil reaalselt staatust. Meil Aa staatust ei ole vaja. Vaadata. Vastab tõele. Me tegelikult tahame ainult, mida
Õpetaja: mida me Tahame tegelikult ainult üldse.
Õpetaja: Me tahame tegelikult sellest vastusest. Ju ainult seda osa Vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Ma võin ju siin üleval kohe öelda, et ära Anna alla kaasa Tervet response. Kui mul on error, siis ma tahan veel status koodi vaadata ja mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Aga me tegelikult siin kontekstis Soovin ainult neid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Siis siin Ma ei panekski üldse response, vaid siin. Me Paneks juba Locations, sest et
Õpetaja: siin on Location Id üks, Kaks, kolm Saate ma üldiselt aru
Õpetaja: Tegelikult hea tava ongi anda Alla Lihtsalt alamme kõige väiksem osa, mida tegelikult on, vaja
Õpetaja: Ega see midagi Muidugi ei muuda, kui ma annan niimoodi ka vaata
Õpetaja: teemegi seekord niimoodi. See olekski tegelt hea. Tava. Ei ole vajavas. Seda jälgib palju rohkem Javas jälgib palju märksa. Rohkem seda Anna Helper meetodile. Kui see on mingi objekt, kus on palju andmeid sees, Anna sellele objektile kaasa ainult See, Mida tal on vaja
Õpetaja: selles kohas, kus sa välja kutsud.
Õpetaja: Ja ma saan ja samamoodi mul on, kui ma tahaksin anda student ja Studentil on first name, last name ja mingi age date. Ma tahaksin anda näiteks, et see on student
Õpetaja: ja ma tahan ainult kaasa anda teema. Date of Birthday on Niukene väli Date of Birth.
Õpetaja: Siis Ma ainult selle kaasa annaksingi. Kui sellel mäletate. Seda Ket cappuccino,
Õpetaja: teed cappuccino Anna mulle kohvi, oad ja mida iganes. Vaatab mulle ühes objektis kõik andmed. Nagu. Vaata, et, ee, palju vett on vaja. Palju kohvi jube on vaja Palju On vaja midagi muud. Ma ei anna tervet seda objekti alla. Nagu Kui ma tahan vett saada, ma ütlen, anna mulle meetodi Teen niimoodi, et tema võtab sisse voter. Milliliters
Õpetaja: on meetod? Getwater.
Õpetaja: See on defineeritud. Siis kui see oleks siin Gat Water, teen lihtsalt Gatwater. Meetod ja ruttu. Noh, Gatwater,
Õpetaja: siin ei ole pointi. Vaata, et ee, cappuccino
Õpetaja: või teed geneerimised kohvi, kohvi, settings
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette, et seal on siis erinevad väljad küljes. Water Equirement. Ee, Mitu grammiinse ma teeksin Getwater? Siis ma paneks nagu Water
Õpetaja: Milliliiters.
Õpetaja: Midagi taolist ja see koht, Kus ma välja kutsuks? Näitaks seda No ma korra praegu. Siis
Õpetaja: Aa, kus ma kirjutaks? Ma kirjutan siit sellest koodi. Siis sealt Niimoodi näed This gate Water.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma sinna kaasa. Kui mul oleksin. Ee objekt. Led kohvi settings Sinu jaoks mingi objekt.
Õpetaja: Ütlen niimoodi. What paneme ee Kakskümmend grammi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Water.
Õpetaja: Mm, Water.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea sada milli.
Õpetaja: Vot Ee, Ml. Näiteks nii oleme midagi veel.
Õpetaja: Paneme näiteks Mis veel. Kohvi juures käib veel, Milk.
Õpetaja: Noh, paneme mingi kümme milli.
Õpetaja: Kohvi settings Näed See, Selles mõttes on ee objekt
Õpetaja: ja. Kui ma tahan seda gatwater It käivitada. Ma tõstan ta siia alla korra niimoodi et oleks silmale lähemal. Mina tahan nüüd Ee Gatwater It käivitada,
Õpetaja: Siis mul mul oleks võimalik teha niimoodi, et kogu kohvisettings läheb sinna alla kogu see objekt
Õpetaja: ja ma saan selle meetodi teha ka niimoodi, Vaata et ta võtabki
Õpetaja: kogu asja kaasa näed? Anna kogu objekt.
Õpetaja: Aga Mõistlikum oleks hoopis see et, alla annab ainult. Seda et, kuule kui, palju voterit On vaja
Õpetaja: Ja Siis selle väljakutsumise. Ma ütlen kohvi Settings punkt
Õpetaja: Motorml I. Annan selle kaasa. See abimeetod võtab ainult selle kaasa, mida tal vaja on,
Õpetaja: Noh, meil on põhimõtteliselt siin sama sama Case hetkel. Tegelikult, et. Ee. Ärme annagi kaasa seda responsi kaasa.
Õpetaja: Anname hoopis respons ja data kaasa Ja oma meetodis, kus me kirjutame respons. Meil tulebki juba sisse. Ainult
Õpetaja: So Jason Saate aru, et siis mõistlik
Õpetaja: noh. Nüüd, me oleme lõpuks Siin kohas, kus meil. Ee, me saame mingisuguseid andmeid, Aga meil on hetkel nagu. Et. Aga kuhu me selle paneme? Ärme unusta, mis meie Eesmärk on Me Eesmärk On siin See tabel Ju
Õpetaja: Locations.
Õpetaja: Kõik need read peavad tulema Locations andmetest.
Õpetaja: Mis me siis nüüd tegema peame?
Õpetaja: Kuskil See. See on see alumine Kiviplokk. See on see ülemine kiviplokk Datasse on vaja ühte muutujat.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, teame. Step by Step vaatame, kus Eelmine asi lõppeb. Citys lõpeb siin.
Õpetaja: Ütleme see paar tühja rida.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla selle muutuja nimi?
Õpetaja: Noh, siin on väga lihtne vastus,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla selle muutuja nimi
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt Locations. Kui me tegime, siis nagu sa ei peaks ju mängima, siis sellega kokku.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on muutu ja Nüüd on küsimus, et mis tüüpi ta on?
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd me nüüd teeme?
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja nagu öelda, nagu mis mingi algväärtust on tal ka enda vaja. Aga tegelikult on see mudel,
Õpetaja: mis meil on vaja teha, Võid see vihje ära ju
Õpetaja: kopeerida sealt. Noh, võibolla oleme täpsemad. Kas ma kopeerin siit või mis sa selle all mõtled?
Õpetaja: Piiblist?
Õpetaja: Piiblist peab ju vaatama, mida see teenus tagastab.
Õpetaja: No siis ongi. See Lähme Piiblisse
Õpetaja: Nüüd praegult. See näide, mis on siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, Näete, siin on kopinupp ka Kusjuures Ikkagi on olemas Näete all.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Siin. Selles on Mitmekordne representation. Vaata vastavalt. Näi, ta paneb kogu näidise siia eksemplisse, aga päriselus elus genereeritakse see jaava klassi pealt lihtsalt mudelina. Kui sul on list,
Õpetaja: siis see tähendab seda, et ta algab kandiliste sulgudega. Kui seal on objekt objekt näiteks mingi location tto. Mis iganes mingi klassist, siis On lihtsalt see ühekordne representatsioon. Sellest.
Õpetaja: Aga meie praegult võtame Kogu selle asja koos sulgede ja karvadega Copy.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd tuleme, paneme niimoodi siia Pläraki selle maha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kas ta tegi teil jälle need kvootidega või mitte?
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, alustame kõigepealt sellest, et Massiivis on mitmeid elemente, tõmbaks nad kõigepealt kokku. Niimoodi Vaata, et meil oleks silmad nagu hea näha. Näete, tulete selle joone juurde. Mitte see pirn, onju? Vaid siia. Põmm,
Õpetaja: Järgmine kokku järgmine kokku. Mitu objekti on siin sees?
Õpetaja: Okei, see on siis
Õpetaja: kolm Meil tegelikult mudeli mõttes ei ole vaja. Meil ei ole Andmete mõttes ka. Me ei soovigi oma koodi. Neid Tegelikult neid tegevväärtusi.
Õpetaja: Siis mis me tegema peame?
Õpetaja: Meil. Meil ei ole vaja nagu siukest näidist.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja lihtsalt mudelit. Jätame ühe. Ega me hakkame sellest viimasest pihta niimoodi. Üks, kaks, kolm ja kustutame selle lohiseva koma ka Ära Pole vaja
Õpetaja: Eliit.
Õpetaja: Noh, äkki inimesed praegu mõtleks, kus see on. Ju no backspace. Iga saab ka Vahet. Pole sama tulemus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me Võime selle lahti teha,
Õpetaja: kui teil on siin need Ee, tag Id.
Õpetaja: Tehke lihtsalt kogu see asi niisuguseks siniseks.
Õpetaja: Tulge kollase pirni juurde ja Teil on Unquote Property names.
Õpetaja: Ma ei hakka. No ma võin korra panna peale. Ta paneb üksikumad. Teil on, ee, arvatavasti topelt, onju? Vahet pole tema jaoks need koodid täpselt samamoodi. Refaktor mitte refaktor. Vabandust, Pirn.
Õpetaja: Unquote,
Õpetaja: See on ka. Seda ei olnud alati kogu aeg. Ma tegin Lihtsalt, Ee, Otsi neid. Ee, topelt ülakomasid ja kustutan need ära. Ma mingit triki kasutasin. Nüüd on see, et siin on algväärtused. No me ei soovi seda neid näiteid. Me lihtsalt soovime mudelit.
Õpetaja: See kaksteist võiks asendada. Millega
Õpetaja: nüüd annab märku, et tegemist on number, aga aga tõesti Ta Ei olegi mingi number.
Õpetaja: No see võiks olla lihtsalt null.
Õpetaja: Ahah, siin. Käed numbrid.
Õpetaja: Ei ole vaja siin sikupilli prismat, vaid piisab Jah, Kustutame kõik need sisu ära
Õpetaja: nii nüüd, mudeli mõttes. On Siin endiselt midagi üleliigset, mis? Siin on Üleliigset,
Õpetaja: Jah, et kas siin on ju Näidatakse, et siin on Massiiv samamoodi, et Locations on massiiv ja meil on nagu, et. Aa, et. Okei, siin on niuksed väljad niuksel objektil,
Õpetaja: Aga See on omakorda massiiv. Siin on jälle. Vaata, kui me tõmbame kokku. Need niimoodi.
Õpetaja: On siin kokku kolm näidet on nii,
Õpetaja: aga meil Ei ole vaja neid näiteid. Meil on vaja ainult mudelist aru saada. Siis mis me teeme.
Õpetaja: Ja mis on teil lihtsam pä ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Süsteemi pealt genereeritud svägerid, et seal ongi juba niuke näidis.
Õpetaja: Kus on kõik ühekordsed, Sest et see on skeema, See on mudel,
Õpetaja: et mis Mis and Mis väljad on objektis? Nüüd on meil teada. Nüüd Intellige ei teab Selle näitab veel niikuinii, onju? Aga nüüd ta teab, et Meil on siin massiiv objektidest.
Õpetaja: Meil on igas objektis Neli välja. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli. On Location Ides transaction types I kohta. Tead, see on eraldi massiiv objektidest objektidest, kus iga objekti sees on. Välitransaction Type Name.
Õpetaja: Mudel on olemas ka algväärtuste kuju. Need on algväärtused. Tegelikult Noh, Algselt, kui lehte laetakse, siis ongi Location I sees üks objekt. See sama objekt, mis me praegu tegime. See on algväärtus samamoodi, nagu meil on algväärtused. Näiteks City Id. Esialgne väärtus on null
Õpetaja: või user. Id on mis iganes saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Nii by the way ee meil ei lähe selles vaates vaja. User Id Dega.
Õpetaja: Meil hiljem läheb vaja. Ja ma tahtsin näidata, et kuidas neid kätte saada ja nii edasi, Sest et taaskis oli ülesanne. Lihtsalt tõesta ära, et sa oled võimeline saama neid andmed kätte. Sellele asjale Ütleme saionara. Kustutame ära. Need
Õpetaja: Pole vaja neid.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meil on olemas see mudel,
Õpetaja: mis vastab sellele sellele. Niiöelda, kuidas meil on kontrakt
Õpetaja: Back end iga. Meil on selline kokkulepe et responsist tuleb selline sisu.
Õpetaja: Super, väga tore.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Locations on olemas Võime selle Brad kokku tõmmata. Meil pole seda võibolla vaja nii väga Vaadata üldse kogu data blok datablokas olla, onju? Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd me tuleme tagasi. Siia. See me jäimegi seda. Siia, Vaata et me, saame vastuse, Vastus pannakse niukse sildi. Taha. Me ütleme, toimetame sellega vastusega Meetodis kaasa. Ei anna tervet responsi, vaid anname ainult seda. Jason, I Mis tuleb
Õpetaja: See sama asi
Õpetaja: siin. Ütleme, et siin meetodis ütleme juba, et meie võtame sisse mingisuguse objekti. No see ongi nüüd see objekt
Õpetaja: kogu selles Hiilguses see ongi see response data.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: ma ei mäleta, kas panin selle plöraka sinna maha või ei pannud?
Õpetaja: Siin vist tegime seda.
Õpetaja: Tuleb See meelde respons on kogu respons.
Õpetaja: Staatus Staatus tekst. Igasugused headerid asjad. Mida siis siin ei näe?
Õpetaja: Sponsor sees, punkt data, nagu see on Kogu objekt sügavamale. Neid neid osasid saab nagu punktiga minna Sügavamale. Punkt staatus Punkt. Staatus tekst. Sellest Nimest on vale, aga vahet vale punkt Data, See on Data respons. Body on see
Õpetaja: ee, teistes terminoloogiates.
Õpetaja: Näed selle sellest osast? Andsime ainult selle jaseni siia. Alla. Selle asja nimi on Location.
Õpetaja: Mis on siis meie esimene asi, et nüüd edasi? See on jälle see, et kui see nüüd see sildikene elab ja sureb Siin see info, mis praegult see asi on Juba kutupiilu Põhimõtteliselt, kui see kood jookseb.
Õpetaja: Kui juba see meetod käivitub, siis siin juba põhimõtteliselt on tegevused otsa saanud.
Õpetaja: See response sildik. Seda Aga see objekt on juba kadunud. Vaata, see sildik on kadunud. Objekt on alles. See objekt on siin. Praegu
Õpetaja: tegelt ei ole. Seda tervet objekti enam polegi. On ainult osaline osa sellest objektist. See elab siin,
Õpetaja: tema ka elab ja sureb siin ära. Aga meie plaan on see, et ma tahaks seda selle sisu pealt
Õpetaja: teha oma ridu.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis on vaja kuskilt talletada Ja kuidas me saame, Share? Ida,
Õpetaja: Me juba tegime selle keha ära. Aga hetkel on see täpselt selline sisu, nagu meil siin on.
Õpetaja: See peab nüüd uuenema.
Õpetaja: Mis? Me kirjutame siis
Õpetaja: Dislocations? Praegult on see, et me näpuga katsume. Seda Me saaks seda infot kuvada või midagi teha, Aga me ei taha teda kuvada, vaid Me tahame,
Õpetaja: mis sa tahad, vä?
Õpetaja: Me saame talle väärtust anda. Me tahame sisu talle anda.
Õpetaja: Kus Me saame selle sisu.
Õpetaja: See meetod
Õpetaja: saigi selle Sisu. Siia. Sellest ta elab. Vaadake, mis värvi on praegu. Locations Fall. Ma kirjutan siia, Locations,
Õpetaja: Mõlemad on valged. Teine on lilla
Õpetaja: Klikin. Siia peale helendab see klikin siia peale helendab see, saate aru See on üks sama sildikene.
Õpetaja: Anna sellele sildile Uus objekt ülikama. Mis siin sees praegult on? Ma võin selle, panna et algseis on üldse
Õpetaja: number kaks, lihtsalt number kaks, Ma ei tea, miks.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, Ta saab uue sisu. Ta saab niikuinii uue sisu. Ta saab selle sisu. Mis internetist tuleb? Siis tuleb responsist Täpsemalt Data St.
Õpetaja: Noh, loomulikult. Ma ei soovi, et ta oleksin kaks. Ma soojen, et oleks mudel, et ma saaks normaalselt progeda,
Õpetaja: eriti seal üleval. Noh, ülevalt hakkab pakkuma asju. Miks? Sest et mudel on ette antud.
Õpetaja: Meil on küsimus, kas midagi muud on veel vaja teha?
Õpetaja: Noh, tegelikult ega ei olegi, Sest et. Selle meetod Get Locations ongi eesmärk. Anna mulle andmeid,
Õpetaja: mis puudutab seda handel Get Locations Response on Done Jd Job, Done.
Õpetaja: Aga vaatame, kas kuidas saan vaadata, et kas asi töötab. Või öelge mulle teie
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan vaadata, et see asi teatud.
Õpetaja: Noh, võin valida. Tuleb see alert, mis on programmeeritud ja.
Õpetaja: Aga ega midagi rohkem. Aga ma küsin,
Õpetaja: Me ei olegi praegult neid andmeid laetakse. Aga me ei tee nendega veel mitte midagi. Aga ma ütlen ikkagi, et kuidas. Ma saan vaadata, et see asi toimib
Õpetaja: korrektselt, Midagi Ei ole valesti, et back end. Saadan. Back Ile midagi valesti ja saan mingi errori või midagi.
Õpetaja: No keegi juba ütles. Ee, Network. Vist Midagi vä F. Kaksteist. Network, palun. Väga
Õpetaja: Tuled Networki alla. Ma tõmban selle konsooli osa veits allapoole.
Õpetaja: Kui teil Refresh, i, siis ta monitoorib, et mis sõnumid lähevad. Mul ta näitab kõiki asju, mis siit läheb. Vaata aga, paneme Fetch sõnumi, Mis läheb Fetchiga,
Õpetaja: toob ära. Need linnaandmed on? Näeme, et läheb ka sõnum. No mis läheb sõnum? Näeme, et läheb kett. Sõnum
Õpetaja: läheb sket. Sõnum lõppeb ära siin
Õpetaja: ja läheb. Ee quer I Parameeter Ee. Urli parameeter.
Õpetaja: City Id Väärtusega Null Läheb status kakssada. Tähendab Et, vist kõik läks hästi
Õpetaja: Ju Siis see den Block käivitub, eksole?
Õpetaja: Kui vaatame Response, siis näeme, et tuligi vastus sikupilli prisma tondi Selver Tartu jõeprisma.
Õpetaja: Okei, me saame ka voega vaadata, tegelikult, sest Me progesime ju ära, et uus sisu, mis tuleb Response punkt. Data oli nii?
Õpetaja: Võtad vahe tööriista lahti siit alt juba seekord, mugavalt vaid Ta Atms View.
Õpetaja: Vaatad Locationsi alla. Harrai kolm, vaatad lahti.
Õpetaja: Sikupilli, Prisma, koos.
Õpetaja: Raha sisse, raha väljamaksed tondiselver, koos Ka sisseraha välja viimane jõeprisma,
Õpetaja: raha sisse lähe välja, on nii?
Õpetaja: See tähendab, seda, et Location isi sees on andmed.
Õpetaja: Mis on Complete?
Õpetaja: Super, lähme edasi. Me istud. Edasi,
Õpetaja: Noh, meil on siin checklist on ees põhimõtteliselt vä.
Õpetaja: Mis Edasi, Catch? Ups, midagi läks valesti. Vaata, mis taas selle kohta ütleb.
Õpetaja: Edukas päring. Jah, seda just tegime.
Õpetaja: Hea vastusega. Päring ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati. Error kaks, kaks.
Õpetaja: Kui Kui saadakse staatus nelisada neli,
Õpetaja: no siin pannakse ja viga. Kaks, kaks, siis kuvada sõnumist saadud message vea teada.
Õpetaja: Mm, okei.
Õpetaja: No Millest alustame?
Õpetaja: Istume siin kätši Sees, nooleke vilgub valdige nüüd öö,
Õpetaja: Mida on vaja, Kuna me juba eelnevalt oleme seda teinud ja
Õpetaja: programmeerinud, siis siin peaks olema viide sinna Navigation Service
Õpetaja: ja peale seda ja Aga Navigation Service läheb. Ups, Midagi läks valesti,
Õpetaja: aga siin on rohkem olukordi. No see Ups, Midagi läks valesti. On igas sõnumis, aga siin on
Õpetaja: Valge error. Vaata, onju. Okei, aga räägi, mis asi see valge error on?
Õpetaja: Mi? Mis? Mis meil on vaja Praegult hetkel käivitub see Blokk, kui tuleb. Ee, paha olukord. Aga mis nüüd on meil vaja, et me saaksime programmiga suhelda.
Õpetaja: Me saaksime programmi, et et tuleb mingi paha vastus ja me tahame sinna vastuse sisse vaadata, mis meil on vaja.
Õpetaja: Noh, seda on vaja.
Õpetaja: Silti on vaja see osa nüüd silt Mõtle nimeline silt välja
Õpetaja: No kui tuleb mingi paha asi, siis inglise keeles võiks olla see, et mingi error on.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tahaks selle Erroriga midagi teha,
Õpetaja: siis selline Landa Syntax ütleb. Nüüd me käivitame nüüd. Lihtsalt käivitasid. Mingi kood? Lihtsalt siit. Kood lihtsalt käivitub. Mida iganes sa kirjutad, Lihtsalt Javascript kood.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me Jällegi, me ei taha. Me Peame hakkama vaatama, et mis seal sees on, Mis seal toimub, Kas on staatus? Mis Iganes, bla, bla, bla. Me ei taha kirjutada seda koodi siia
Õpetaja: ei taha. Nüüd oleks kõik see niimoodi loetamatu. Kräpp on ju? Meil on Niuke Public meetod, kus me tahame näha Get kohvi Getwater
Õpetaja: nagu. Vot see on See Asi on ju, et me tahame öelda seda,
Õpetaja: et me Jah, tahame midagi teha, Aga me ei tee seda asja siin vaid meil on abimeetod,
Õpetaja: kes hakkab meie ees. Toimetama, nüüd et kutsuda välja meetodid, siis me võtame this.
Õpetaja: Siis me kutsume nimelist koodilõiku. Mis võiks olla nimi selles meetodis?
Õpetaja: Noh, esimese sõna võiksime ära mõelda Tegusõna Handle.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on seal Handle Get Locations respons. Kui on nagu Happy Bath, mis võiks olla see,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla see tegevus
Õpetaja: Tähendab
Õpetaja: Muidu kõik päris hea. Aga mitmes locations error, näiteks? Noh, kas response asjad? See on nagu jälle mingi maitse asi,
Õpetaja: et ta oleks Päriselt saaks aru ka, et tegemist on. Meetodid peavad olema need sulud.
Õpetaja: Ja miks need sulud on?
Õpetaja: Miks on need sulud vajalikud?
Õpetaja: Saab kaasa midagi anda. Seda Me tahame kaasa anda.
Õpetaja: Error It.
Õpetaja: Me anname siis selle Erri kaasa Näed? Kui pole. Kui seda silti pole,
Õpetaja: kui seda silti pole. Vaata siis. Väga raske on öelda, et anna kaasa mingisugune info. Kui pole Silti, siis mul oleks siin praegult nagu
Õpetaja: Mm, mm, Vot mismoodi Ma tahan suhelda nende andmetega.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan suhelda nende andmetega, mis mulle Errorist tuleb,
Õpetaja: Aga mul ei ole nagu siin mitte, kui millelegi viidata?
Õpetaja: Ei, no kui ma. Kui ma tahan mingit sisse kirjutatud andmeid. No ma kustutan selle ära Paneme. Kustutame selle ka ära. Ma Panen lihtsalt sulud ümber praegu, et see lõpus tuleb niikuinii.
Õpetaja: Nii, see on nagu anonüümne. Käivita midagi silti. Pole Kui ma tahaksin mingeid andmeid ise anda praegu siia. Kaks, üks,
Õpetaja: mingi objekt. Jah, ma saan sinna anda alla, aga. Aga see ei ole see objekt
Õpetaja: ja see ei Ole need andmed. Vaata, mida mul on vaja. Saate aru, See siin on silt
Õpetaja: silt. On see lihtsalt sildi defineerimine. Samamoodi nagu Vaata siin. Selles. Vaata nagu parameeter. Me loome uue sildi
Õpetaja: koodi sees. Võin iga kell kirjutada let.
Õpetaja: Mingi sildi nimi anda. Talle mingi väärtus silt. Sildi Loomine. Seda kutsutakse
Õpetaja: kohalik muutuja, Mis on meetodi bloki sees?
Õpetaja: See siin on databloki muuta. Võiks kutsuda niimoodi. Kuidagi see siin on parameeter. Muutuja,
Õpetaja: Sildi loomine. Sildi loomine, Sildi loomine. Silt ja objekt on kaks erinevat asja. Vaata, see objekt Hetkel elab meil selle errori sees.
Õpetaja: Selle sildi taga on objekt.
Õpetaja: Kui ma siin ütlen, nagu. Et Hei, kutsu välja meetod Serror. Ja kui ma nüüd siin sildi annan talle ette, siis tegelikult tema mõtleb taustal, kui objekt
Õpetaja: objekti annab edasi.
Õpetaja: Ta on ülikama. Mis selles meetodis pärast on? Kirjas? Nagu mis seal see sildikene on, Sa annad objekti tagasi Veel täpsemalt. Veel täpsemalt. Ehk kui jaamasse läheme.
Õpetaja: Me tegelt. Isegi ei anna objekti kaasa. Me tegelikult anname kaasa siukse asja. Nagu mäluviide. Iga kord kui tekib mingisugune objekt siis arvuti reserveeri kuskil ee spetsiaalses mälus
Õpetaja: ühe väikse supi ühe väikse niukse ruudu kuu Sisse saab tampida informatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Seal ongi päriselt see objekt.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tegelikult nüüd sellel mälusopil on oma mingi viide, mingi referents, mingi mälunumber
Õpetaja: ja tegelikult nüüd ülejäänud aeg, mis päriselt toimub, on üks ja sama objekt on seal samas mälus kogu aeg
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd lihtsalt see viide, mis on viitab sellele konkreetsele ruudule. Vot see seotakse tegelikult muutujaga,
Õpetaja: et tehniliselt võttes kohe hästi. Tehniliselt ütles on niimoodi. See objekt sünnib mälus, mis Tuleb Internetist.
Õpetaja: Sellel Sellel mälul on oma mingisugune. Mingi viide, mingi Id või? Mis iganes,
Õpetaja: Mingi rehv null, null. Kujutage ette mingi viide, Lihtsalt Mingi number, siis ongi niimoodi, et kui mina kirjutan selle selle uue sildikese error, siis see error. See See sildikene saab tegelikult viite sellele mälusopile.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui mina nagu kutsun välja mingi meetodi, siis mina annan selle mäluviite selle sildikese abil. Kuule, ma annan. Ma soovin käivita see Meetod
Õpetaja: Handle Get locations error.
Õpetaja: Ja sellega kaasas käib üks objekt.
Õpetaja: Selle objekti mäluviide seal arvutis on selline. Võta see kaasa ja kuidas tema Nüüd toimetab edasi, Kui ta siin. Kui me võtame. Näiteks kasutame nagu seda näitena
Õpetaja: nüüd selle sildi taga. Tegelikult ongi objekt, aga kuidas tegelikult on mäluviide,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes kujutage ette ma korra joonistan. Vaata kahjuks, kes kodus on, Siis, Ee, peavad.
Õpetaja: Teeme siia. Klassikaline mälu.
Õpetaja: Meil on Ee, rehv, üks.
Õpetaja: Tere, kaks, F, kolm.
Õpetaja: Jah, nii. Kujutame ette, et mälu mäluviide Kui mina lihtsalt koolis tegin Vaatame. Jutumärkidega. Rai lihtsalt tekst,
Õpetaja: Me räägime natuke Jaovast. Praegu Siis me saame ette kujutada, et nüüd on objekt String
Õpetaja: tähtedega R A I, N. See on objekt
Õpetaja: siis Arvuti valib mingisuguse koha. Kui ta paneb selle suvaliselt, paneb näiteks siia siia selle objekti elama.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tal on. Nüüd on. See on see Objekt on siin sees. Ja Tal on oma viide.
Õpetaja: Objekt Tekib Niimoodi silti. Pole veel mänguski, kui me kirjutame siia ette.
Õpetaja: No ma ei Pane tüüpi panema. Pärast nime First.
Õpetaja: Nii siis ta saab põhimõtteliselt ja saab selle. Viite
Õpetaja: ref nii kui mina nüüd programmis kuskil ütlen, nagu Prindikonsooli Print
Õpetaja: Panen siia selle first.
Õpetaja: Nii, mis sul taustal Juhtub kuskil
Õpetaja: jaavas endas. Või on meetod print, siis võtab sisse
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt ta võtab Selles mõttes number String. Aga antud hetkel on Niukene meetod, mis võtab stringi vastu ja seal on näiteks muutuja nimi on Value
Õpetaja: Palun väe, Mis nüüd taustal juhtub, on see, et kui sina kutsud välja selle meetodi prindikonsooli,
Õpetaja: sina ütled, et Kuule, ole, hea, Anna mälu Idrf neli üle.
Õpetaja: Palun panna see üle. Nüüd printmeetod käivitub.
Õpetaja: Siin tekib uus silt.
Õpetaja: Tema saab viite külge.
Õpetaja: Rehv neli.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd siin kooli lõigus on, see siis selle
Õpetaja: siin hakkab, siis see, päris. Kuidas see konsooli tehakse. Seal ongi päris kool, mis hakkab seda konsoli printima. Nüüd, kui tema soovib siis nagu andmetena suhelda selle objektiga, siis tema teab, et tema Vaatab mälus, hoopis referents neli seda objekti ja toimetab.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd tehniline Sellise asja, nagu endale selgeks teete, siis te olete juba mäe kaugusel võrreldes mingisuguse muu. Seltskonnaga kes tegelikult seda asja ei olegi viitsinud kunagi endale selgeks teha.
Õpetaja: Meil on sildid. Meil on objektid ja meil tegelikult on mälu,
Õpetaja: kus asjad on ja kogu aeg, kuidas programm saaks üldse nii kiirelt toimetada.
Õpetaja: Ongi see, Vaata, et sul on mälus need objektid ja kogu aeg annad neid viiteid üle.
Õpetaja: Ta ei saa väga kiirelt toimetada. Ta ei loo uut objekti kogu aeg. Ei ole, niimoodi, et Rain muudkui tekib mällu mingi miljon korda
Õpetaja: ühe korra tekib objekt
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on niimoodi. Ja kuidas see töötab, on, see et kogu aeg. Ee, tegelikult on. Meil on niukene. Jaavas on Niukene vahva tegelane, Nagu ma panen pärast materjali ka
Õpetaja: Kes see jõudis? Kes kes jõudis Collector It kuskil näha? Mälukasutus nii kaugele Keegi ei jõudnud üli ülihea Materjal soovitan soe, et. Vaadake, ma jagan seda.
Õpetaja: Kuidas nüüd, kuidas on? Meil on Niukene edukas, Kes on prügimees?
Õpetaja: Noh, teeb mingi robotit teha Nii,
Õpetaja: Noh, jah, tema on prügimees. Tal on. Tal on siin väike Luud on käes.
Õpetaja: No oota, muuga siin on veits kuidagi peksa saanud, et sa.
Õpetaja: See on see robot vend
Õpetaja: tema vastu. Tema on prügikoguja. Halvasti mingi Horder või mida iganes tegelt on puhastaja, tema ülesanne. On Hoida see asi võimalikult puhas,
Õpetaja: võimalikult puhas. Ja kuidas ta teeb seda? See on nüüd natukene jämedal. Jämedam on see, et iga teatud aja tagant. Tal on mingi oma algoritm, on ju? Ta käib vaatamas mälu
Õpetaja: ja ta vaatab, et kas hetkel on kasvõi üks muutuja, mis viitab sellele objektile.
Õpetaja: Kui kuskil veel skoobis, kood jookseb, on see elus Ja see biit on elus. Siis ta seda ära kustutada ei saa,
Õpetaja: Ei Ole võimalik, nii. Aga kui ta ühel hetkel leiab, et pole enam ühte ainsat viidet sellele objektile,
Õpetaja: siis ta. Sa Vaatab, et oota keegi Näiteks siin on mingi muu objekt. Näiteks mingi.
Õpetaja: Ja Tere, ringlus. Tere, tal ei ole ühtegi viidet.
Õpetaja: Vaatab keegi keegi mulle sellele mälusopile ei viita. Järelikult kustutame ära ja vabastame mälu.
Õpetaja: Kui päris aus olla. Vot siin ongi see asi. Vaata, kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi ja Sa soovid selle informatsiooniga midagi edasi teha. Pane see muutujasse,
Õpetaja: Sest vastasel juhul, kui muutujat ei ole,
Õpetaja: siis juhtubki see asi juhtub täpselt. See asi. Mingisugune meetod saab otsa Seal see viide läheb kustutamisele.
Õpetaja: Must auk
Õpetaja: tuleb, sööb, selle ära. Sul ei ole mitte kuidagi võimalik seda enam kätte saada isegi kui ta veel teda ära söönud. Aga sul ei ole enam ühtegi muutujat, mis viitab sellele. Sul on see referents kadunud For life.
Õpetaja: Vot see ongi see Kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetod, mis midagi tagastab, siis soovid selle info midagi edasi teha, siis sa Pead seda. Return Tegelikult annabki ka samamoodi. Annab, mis ta teeb. Ta annab selle mäluviite üle
Õpetaja: puude kohta. Sa lood uue sildikese stream first Name võrdub ja sa ütled, et mingi kett. Ee, see ongi see, et. Vaata, anna mulle viide sellele objektile seoses selle sildiga,
Õpetaja: Sest et Ma soovin sellega midagi edasi teha. Ja kui seda ei ole enam, siis on ka put.
Õpetaja: Kas see kuidagi kõnetab veidigi?
Õpetaja: Kui te vot niukse asja ära õpiksite. Ausõna, Ma ütlen, ee, on siga palju mingisuguseid juunioreid, kes tegelikult seda värki ei ole. Viitsi kunagi selleks teha, miks Nad lihtsalt õpivad koos koodi. Nad ei õpi nad õpid jalava eksamit tegema. Siis nad peavad sellest asjast aru saama. Noh,
Õpetaja: sertifikaati. Näiteks midagi taolist. Ee, seal Need nüansid on nagu vaja. Teada.
Õpetaja: Nii vaatame ka mingid kodused ka, onju? Ma Panen selle ruttu. Slaki.
Õpetaja: Ee. Ma ei tea, kas sa nii kõvasti karjun. Vaata, kas midagi sinna jõuab. Kas õppematerjali midagi jõuab? Aga ma panen vähemalt Slaki. Mis sa soovisid näha Samal ajal
Õpetaja: Aa, seda nii ma samal ajal panen. Ruttu slaki ära. Siis mul ei ole meelest.
Õpetaja: Panen generali alla
Õpetaja: pildid,
Õpetaja: Palun, väga uhke Carbage Collector.
Õpetaja: Ee vahetunnil. Keegi tuletab meelde, Siis otsin. Ee, otsin ühe. Materjali ja panen lingi ka. Ee, põnev lugemine. Noh, mulle tundub, et on? Kõik on seal kenasti ära tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ee, Jõudsime siis siia, et me saime kätte selle Error I. Siin on sildikene. Miks on sildikene? Sest et meil on vaja seda objekti mäluviidet. Me kutsume välja meetodi. Mida hetkel ju veel ei ole olemas. Kaasa. Anname jälle selle viite. No nüüd on vaja teha see meetod
Õpetaja: päriselt ei ole sellist nimelist koodi lõiku lahti.
Õpetaja: Create Function Property paneb siia kõige alla, lihtsalt kõike entriga lihtsalt läbi lüüa.
Õpetaja: Ja jällegi tõstame selle lihtsalt ülesse poole, et Vaata, me kirjutame koodi. Siin
Õpetaja: ta võiks minna põhimõtteliselt me vaatame klikid Sellele onju, mis siin on? See meetod asub kuskil mujal. Järjekorra mõttes Midagi peame mõtlema. See meetod asub kuskil siin. Ee, selles ee, selles failis. Ta võiks ju kohe järgneda. Siis tuleb mingi järgmine. Meetod. Aa, okei. Kuule, aga see on siin kuskil all hoopis, aga tõstaks siis selle siit
Õpetaja: niimoodi korrektselt kontrolliks tuleks. Paneks näiteks selle meetodi järgi
Õpetaja: Koma Peab ka panema, vaata et seal, koma ei olnud automaatselt,
Õpetaja: aga ma ei tekitanud meetodit, vaid ma avasin pirni.
Õpetaja: Näete, kui ei, mäleta tule Hooverda siin peal, mis ta ütleb Show Context Actions.
Õpetaja: Sa saad siia peale vajutada Või sa oled siin kohal ja ütled, et Ava pirn minu eest. See on kogu aeg üks sama punane pirn. Kollane pirn, Rohelist pirni pole veel mina näinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, ilmselt saaks seda ka siis avada. Samamoodi
Õpetaja: Näete, Error läheb kaasa. Oled nõus?
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on siis See asi, et mis meil siin öeldakse,
Õpetaja: võibolla parandaks seda ko. Hästi, natukene.
Õpetaja: Ee, Teeks täpsemalt,
Õpetaja: mis me tegema peame?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui võibolla taaskis on, et kui. No Come on If, see on nagu.
Õpetaja: See on olukord. Mis on see meie peamine tööriist? Kuidas me saame nagu programmis, Nagu protsessi juhtida nagu ühes suunas või teises suunas.
Õpetaja: If iftis. If that do something.
Õpetaja: Noh, If.
Õpetaja: No ma võin selle sealt võtta selle Niimoodi, kui see teid aitab, pange kas kui endale taaski juurde vaata. Onju Tehke see koodikeha ka ära.
Õpetaja: Nii et meil tuleb see If Blokk, onju? Aga nüüd ongi küsimus, et mis see ifi tuleb, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui saadakse Http staatus, nelisada, neli ja Err kood on kaks kaks
Õpetaja: Mm. Nüüd võiks üldse selles mõttes teha ka, et kuskil võiks seda vastust hoida, et jällegi meil oleks mudel
Õpetaja: Kui vaadata piiblit siis error koodi puhul Ta saadab meile niukse asja.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja ühte muutujat.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle käsitsi vaheliseks. Vaata, võtame kui see Locations lõpeb,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla selle asja nimi. No tegelikult, kui te teete lahti, kus me viimati kasutasime? Loginil tuli ju mingi. Error. Vale kasutaja. Nimi Parool. Et Kui me läheme, otsime datablokist üles Error response. See
Õpetaja: Scop I paste Ime. Selle Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: oleks meil siis kõik oleks kuskil ühe korra defineeritud
Õpetaja: Ee, meil selles mõttes tuleb. Meil ei ole typescript I
Õpetaja: ee. Jumal hoidku, peaks seda ka veel õpetama. Seal on veel rohkem abstraktsiooni.
Õpetaja: Ee Du Sun.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd see. Vot see on nüüd asi, mida teha. Kui te hakkate. Nüüd lõpuks aa lähete siit, panete selle ukse enda Selja tagant kinni. Peale nädal kuus või nädal Seitse vastavalt. Ke. Kes ee. Tuleb? Sinna Viimasesse või mitte.
Õpetaja: Nii siis ee, soovitus. Kui te Lähete nüüd koju ja mõtlete, mida teha, Siis kõige tähtsam asi, mis te võiksite teha, on see, et hakkate mingit projekti tegema. Tehke kooliprojekt uuesti
Õpetaja: üksinda.
Õpetaja: Tehke script. Iga
Õpetaja: see on sama asi, aga keerulisem selles Noh, ta on keerulisem, aga paremad seal on niimoodi, et tüübid on kindlad. Seal on nagu niuksed failid. Vaata, mis ütlevad, Vaata, mis? Miks. Üks, milline. Üks või teine objekt on,
Õpetaja: et päriselt, mis väljalt saab, et see on. Nagu. See on See eelis on see, et sul keegi annab kohe märku. Kui sa teed kohe kuskil mingisugust jama
Õpetaja: kuskile Numbri sisse suruv tähte. Noh, midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Süntaks on jälle keerulisem. Abstraktsiooni on üksjagu juures.
Õpetaja: Aga thats it an extop.
Õpetaja: Nii koppisime meie siit Selle
Õpetaja: Paneme selle Login View kinni. Lähme tatablokki. See on täpselt sama formaat. Sa hakkad korduma meil koguaeg.
Õpetaja: Mõte on see et iga, kord, Kui me saame niiöelda eelarve spons I, siis paneme ta korra siia, sest edaspidi on vaja selle pealt programmeerida, siis me kasutame õigeid väljanimesid, Mingeid taiposi asju ei teki
Õpetaja: kuskile. Taaski. Ei pea vaatama. Nagu Aa Svägerit ei pea vaatama. Meil on informatsioon olemas. Ehk esimene samm on See Paneme selle
Õpetaja: selle sisu sinna. Error response, mis me saame Siis me saame toimetada nende väljadega mõnusal message Error Kood
Õpetaja: Mis ma. Siis Kirjutan, kuidas see saab endale uue sisu. Just tegime Location. Iga näiteks.
Õpetaja: Siis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Viitan siis sellele, mis siin, on. See on keha, Mis see on jälle? See on sildikene
Õpetaja: sildikene, mida me saame kasutada üleval templetis. Sildikene, mida saame kasutada, vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Noh, super superpuper, mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidagi selle Erroriga hakkab pihta. Aga see on nüüd kogu error. Mina tahan saada Jasonit.
Õpetaja: Kahjuks error on natukene kihilisem objekt,
Õpetaja: et siin küljes ei ole kohe tata, vaid on error Response punkt. Data, Vot nii.
Õpetaja: No tema jälle ütleb, et ma ei ole kindel, mis siin on, et kas sealt tuleb täpselt selline asi? Ee, we Dont care
Õpetaja: typescript lahendaks selle asja ise taustal Ära
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: ühtlasi Kui tahaks, Kui tahaks, saaks teha ka niimoodi et
Õpetaja: ütleme muutuja Kuidas selle saab kätte Error Punkt response punkt staatus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil olemas See sisuline Jason, mis tuleb? Backend ist. Ja meil on Http status kood
Õpetaja: sellest error sõnumist.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis me nüüd siis kirjutame,
Õpetaja: kui saadakse Nelisada, neli, R Kood on kaks, kaks, siis kuvada sõnumis saadud message.
Õpetaja: Noh, sisu Noh, aidake teie mind. Mina ei oska progeda, mis ma Kirjutan siia, kuidas
Õpetaja: ja ütleme. Viitame jälle selle. Sta, See on sildikene, onju? Kui status kood.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma siia kirjutan,
Õpetaja: võrdub veel, et mida See tähendab, kui status, Mis ma praegu. Mis see tähendab?
Õpetaja: Muudan väärtust. Seda ma ei taha ju teha.
Õpetaja: Tahan tüübikindlalt vaadata, et kas mõlemad Pooled on nelisada. Neli.
Õpetaja: Noh, on on
Õpetaja: mi. Noh, kaks, kaks on nagu. Ma võin kahega alustada ja vaadata, et kas kaks kaks võrdleb,
Õpetaja: Mis, ma kirjutan, see.
Õpetaja: No aga mul ei ole. Ma kirjutan error code. Mm,
Õpetaja: no vot väga. Kus meil andmed on praegu, et selleks Hetkeks on meil need seal kenasti errorespons I sees, onju
Õpetaja: kas teil niimoodi
Õpetaja: jah, Ei, see on ju kogu aeg hetk.
Õpetaja: Siin objektide sees on väljad.
Õpetaja: Jah, nii see. Nüüd on See tingimus,
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd?
Õpetaja: Mm, ven Wen what we gonna do than.
Õpetaja: Siis kuvada sõnumist saadud message Sisu, Kust me seda kuvada tahame?
Õpetaja: Kas mingisuguses Alerdis, mis hüppab ette või kuidagi visuaalselt ikka,
Õpetaja: et. No ma mõtlen nagu mis mis me teha. Tahame sellega. Siin on kuvasõnumist saadud sisu. Meil on ette öeldud, et ta peab olema tegelikult taski järgi, nagu
Õpetaja: on öeldud otsa valas Jah, nii ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati.
Õpetaja: No see on paigutus. Ma paneks ta siia. Tegelikult selle pangaautomaadi ülesse või alla. Vahet pole, aga mis See siin on.
Õpetaja: Asi on, aitäh.
Õpetaja: On see kasv?
Õpetaja: Okei, ma lihtsalt küsin, mis asi see on, Nagu siin nagu üldiselt nagu prooviks seda elementi kuidagi defineerida. Mis asi on
Õpetaja: su mingi peateade?
Õpetaja: On see kuidagi varem meil läbi käinud.
Õpetaja: Kuidas on see läbi käinud
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: ja kõik Tulbat täideti. Teine variant oli isegi see, et. Et ee, vale kasutaja. Nimi Bürool on ju tuleb meelde.
Õpetaja: No ei tule meelde. Ma olen Isegi ära progetud ja logi välja logi sisse. Mäletad, kui paned siia error, siis tegelikult ütleme. Anna mulle viga.
Õpetaja: Mis asi on, No Come on? Ma. Kas siis teeme niimoodi või
Õpetaja: kahjuta? Niimoodi ei näita.
Õpetaja: Noh, Mis asi see on?
Õpetaja: Terror. Terror viimis peaks olema
Õpetaja: Error Views Error View on? S ei ole niukest asja mäleta. Error View on üldse selline asi
Õpetaja: see on. Palun, siin ei ole ju. Ahah, ole eriti Mis asi, mis asi on meil?
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma võiks seda üldiselt nimetada? Mis asi ta on?
Õpetaja: Ta on komponent.
Õpetaja: Klotsmide saab taaskasutada.
Õpetaja: No lähme, Vaatame, kas tõesti. Meil oli ju. Kui ma tahaks veenduda. Ma võin ju ruttu vaadata ka. Ära vaata, et
Õpetaja: meil siin üleval oli mingisugune Errori kuvamine oli nii.
Õpetaja: Error on Niukene klots, mis on eraldi meil siin klotside all komponents all.
Õpetaja: Et Temale tuleb sisse. Props Error Message
Õpetaja: Kui Error message il on mingi sisu, siis seda Tv ei näidatakse. Kui ei ole mingit sisu, siis seda Tv ei näidata,
Õpetaja: kas vist On midagi sarnast asja vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me nüüd tuleme oma sse, siis on läinud küsimus, et kus me seda näidata tahame?
Õpetaja: No Mina pakuks välja. Vaata, et meil on siin kaks road. Ühes on see pangaautomaadid
Õpetaja: Teises saab see tabel olla. Kui me tahaks. Täpselt nii, nagu Siis ta peaks tabel ülesse tulema. Aga ta on. Veitseb. Muidugi kentsakas. Ma pigem paneks ta lihtsalt siia
Õpetaja: pangaautomaatide ülesse või alla, vastavalt soovile, kuhu tahame panna.
Õpetaja: Me paneme üles, Kui see kuidagi on imelik, välja me saame alati muuta, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: No kuidas ma saan nüüd seda Alert Errorit. Nagu et kuva. Nagu selle templi, Mis ma siin tegema pean,
Õpetaja: Tv? I pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Ma olen ühe korra näidanud, et. Noh, ma pole väga teinud seda. Vaata, et kas vastab tõele, et me tahaksime, et seal Rtr I sisu tuleb siia
Õpetaja: Nagu asemele.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis me viitame sellele komponendile, Mis tähtedega ta algab.
Õpetaja: Ja suured tähed. A ja E.
Õpetaja: Aa, ta mõtleb kuule kas sina Tasub korra noolega alla tulla. Kas sa mõtled seda Alert Errorit? Mis on voe komponent?
Õpetaja: Sest kui me nüüd seda teeme, siis ta teeb Igast impordid ja asjad ära sätetes. Ma teen korra, enne kui ma seda teen. Ma teen korra lihtsalt vahepealse. Kas keegi tahab järgi tulla? Ma pean ootama või ei pea
Õpetaja: Davai keegi. Võite tulla järgi praegult.
Õpetaja: Kas teeme sama täna moodi, et teeme kaksteist viieteistkümneni, Ja siis ee, Kell üks tagasi sobib.
Õpetaja: Ma pean lihtsalt siis ruttu mingi Aa
Õpetaja: timer viisteist minutit.
Õpetaja: Kui prääksprääks tuleb, siis nagu räägin poisiga. Kui tuleb, praegu Siis kiigad. Kiigakaga on läbi.
Õpetaja: Siis läheme tuppa. Nii
Õpetaja: Ee, ma tegin ära. Ee, push, it. Saate järgi tulla. Kes tahab mina samal ajal Lihtsalt nagu tahan näidata.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis? Ma tahtsin näidata. Ahah, et kui ma kutsun selle välja ja panen tab
Õpetaja: ja panen siia kaldkriipsu seda üksiktägiga. Tahame seda kutsuda välja. Siis vaatame taustal, mis juhtus. See ei ole ainus muudatus. Tuli See alert error, mis ma just kirjutasin, kui Ma lähen noolega alla. Vaatan, mis muudatused on. Veel tuli. Niukene import
Õpetaja: ja tuli ka Niukene komponent. Siis öeldakse et siin me kasutame Aa Htm, I osas kuskil Alert Errorit. Need kaks asja, nagu mängivad omavahel kokku.
Õpetaja: Selle kolmandaga saate aru. Sellepärast
Õpetaja: me nagu otsime seda niimoodi ülesse Või ütleme Tabiga valikust, et ide teeb ülejäänud liigutused meie eest.
Õpetaja: No kui siit Alert Errorit natukene vaadata, panna kontroll Üks tühike kontroll tühiks On näha ka, et ootab tegelikult sisse Propsina informatsiooni Rmses.
Õpetaja: No hetkel ma võin siia panna mingi tere ja vaadata korra lehelt.
Õpetaja: Pangaautomaadid. Tere, on nii?
Õpetaja: Tere, Tere, printsiibis. Kui on sisu, siis tuleb error.
Õpetaja: Kui ei ole, kui on, siis tuleb. Ja kui ei, ole, siis ei Näita
Õpetaja: no mis? Võibolla väga ei meeldi
Õpetaja: See laius tundub natukene rets, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma seda saan juba vä.
Õpetaja: Aa, see on eelmine asi. Sorry, see on lihtsalt mul kell kaksteist sai. Nii siis mõtlesin. Mis asi nagu
Õpetaja: tele kirjutada. Ja mis mõttes on kadunud juba niimoodi, et See aeg lähebki, onju?
Õpetaja: Et ee, printsiibis. Me ei saa sisse kirjutada
Õpetaja: Siia seda väärtust, on nii? Vaid see peab tulema dünaamiliselt. Noh, Mis See, koha peaks meile trigerdama? Pea siis, mis? Me peame tegema, mida meil on? Vaja.
Õpetaja: Ei, kooloniga ei ole hetkel veel midagi teha, Ma ütlen, I tell you that.
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: vee mudelit? Me ei soovi siin tehase poole üldse. See, mida ma otsin, ma räägin seda, et Meil on probleem selles, et see tekst
Õpetaja: peab dünaamiliselt tulema ja minema tühjaks.
Õpetaja: Tühi sees. Tühi sees. Näita
Õpetaja: ära näita Ma ei saa koodi Kirjutada seda, mida meil on vaja üldse Selle jaoks,
Õpetaja: mis me. Mis siin, mille. Mis me siin peame tegema
Õpetaja: Parameeter on see, et näed alla läheb. Kui ma ütlen siia, siis ta näitab, et näed alla. Voolab siia sisse Mingi string
Õpetaja: Aus ei ole see, kas vastab tõele, et kui siia tuleb mingi sisu, See voolab siia alla. Propsi,
Õpetaja: siin Veef. Iga näidatakse seda Div I näidatakse lihtsalt seda sisu Css, iga saab Alerta Alert Changer
Õpetaja: Sisu. Küsimus on selles, et siit me ei saa sisse programmeerida mingi viga probleem,
Õpetaja: vaid see sisu peab siin muutuma Dünaamiliselt, mis? Meil on selle jaoks vaja, et siia saaks üldse dünaamiliselt midagi panna.
Õpetaja: Okei, Fair Enough. Te olete valel rajal, Fine, ma teen Ei, et siia saaks üldse mingid muutujad panna. Ma panen selle koononi ära. Mis tegelikult teeb, et ma ei taha enam teksti panna,
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: Jah, Fine Whatever nagu lihtsalt ma aitan teid. Mida meil on siin vaja. Mis on siin, puudu, mida meil on vaja, et meil oleks Niuke, Dünaamiline sisu, mida meil on vaja
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja, mida meil on vaja muutujat,
Õpetaja: sest et praegult ei ole niukest muutujat, mida ma saaks kasutada. Ma ei saa kasutada seda error response.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks seda kasutada, aga see Ei,
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja mingisugust muutujat. Vaata, see oligi See, mis ma üritasin teilt välja timmida. Vaata, et meil on mingisugune asi, mis muutub.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja siis muutujat. Kui mingi asi peab muutuma.
Õpetaja: No lähme siia. Sest et me ei. Me saaksime kasutada seda asja ka.
Õpetaja: Aga mina ei, teeks seda,
Õpetaja: sest et mis siis, kui Ma tahan töö nagu ise koodiga anda. Mingi sisu. Siis ma ei tule Error Response punktis
Õpetaja: saaks ide järgi kasutada seda, ka aga me Ei tahaks seda teha.
Õpetaja: Lihtsam on mõnes kohas. Võibolla tahaks nii teha.
Õpetaja: No,
Õpetaja: me võime vaadata Kas see praeguses kontekstis töötaks. Erorespons tuleb ainult, Siis kui sinna objekti tuleb ainult sisu. Kui on meie tingimus,
Õpetaja: ei ole ee ka Viiesaja puhul esimene samm on see, et me täidame Error message i kuidagi ära.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb näiteks Ee internal server Viissada, siis see sisu tuleb hoopis teistsugune. Ja ma ei mäleta, kas seal Message väli on või mitte Ei tahaks teha niimoodi. Pigem tahaks, et meil on eraldi muutuja. Mis võiks olla selle asja nimi?
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja mingisugust sildikest siin, mis läheb alla siia.
Õpetaja: No, mis võiks olla siin? Data blokis selle muutaja nimi,
Õpetaja: mi? Miks ta võiks olla midagi muud erinevat kui see sama
Õpetaja: kõige lihtsam ju, et me siin ütleme, et. Hei, Alerti. Error ootab enda sisse Error Messagit, kus sa oma Sisu saad muutujast nimega
Õpetaja: Error Message.
Õpetaja: See oleks ju kõige mõistlikum nagu. Siis Oleks ju asi väga selge noh. Paneme, siia ülesse
Õpetaja: mis, on Tema vaik algsisu.
Õpetaja: Kui komponent laetakse leht tühist ring koma, paneme, et nad on eraldatud siin niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No ma taas teen niimoodi niuksed. Ühekihilised asjad. Ma topin pigem pigem ülesse poole. Kui mul on siin Selected City Id, panen eed niimoodi ja mitme kihilised asjad ma niimoodi eraldan Ja panen järjest.
Õpetaja: See on Niukene minu niiöelda enda tava.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd me saame siis siduda selle asja ja nüüd on see probleem, et Kui ma panen siia error message
Õpetaja: ma korra kopin selle lihtsalt siis praegult. Tema jaoks.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd jälle see, mis te peate meeles hoidma. Hetkel ta mõtleb, et ma mõtlen teksti Error Message,
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma annan talle tag I sees märku. See on atribuut. Põhimõtteliselt see on see.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma annan märku. Vaatad? Ma mõtlen ikka. Muutujat
Õpetaja: on tühi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen, otsin selle siit välja ja panen lihtsalt mingi, siis See voolab siia
Õpetaja: ja kõik on tip Top.
Õpetaja: No mina loomulikult ei soovi. Millal ma soovin, et see saab uue sisu ainult siis, kui on?
Õpetaja: Saime mingi paha olukorra hand. Ime seda halba olukorda. Siin koodis
Õpetaja: Saame sisu. Saame status koodi. Vaatame, et kui on neli, neli, neli Ja error. Kood kaks, kaks, siis. Sellisel juhul, mis ma tahan teha,
Õpetaja: tahan kuvada kuvada, sõnumi saadud sõnumit. Alert. Message. Is,
Õpetaja: No mida ma Kirjutan siis ja
Õpetaja: üritan talle ette.
Õpetaja: Seda ei taha ju Alert oleks see, et hüppab ette mingi kole asi pole vaja. Mina tahan punasega
Õpetaja: näidata seal üleval No, kui see. Kui see asi siin reageerib sellele sisule,
Õpetaja: kui me tuleme siia lehele tema vaikimise sisu on tühjus ja Seda alerti ei näidata. Siis nüüdses olukorras. Ei tahaks, et ta oleks enam tühi,
Õpetaja: tal Oleks mingi uus väärtus, Siis ma pean lihtsalt viitama Sellele sildikesele, kuidas ma viitan sellele sildikesele?
Õpetaja: Noh, väga hea. See osa, kui ma ütlen.
Õpetaja: Error respons.
Õpetaja: Ei, vabandust, error Message.
Õpetaja: Siit praegu ollakse, et loe selle sisu.
Õpetaja: Aga kui tahan uut sisu anda, siis ma kirjutan. Siia.
Õpetaja: Võrdub nüüd taaskis on öeldud, et sõnumist saadud message sisu tuleb siia panna, siis mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: No kui ma kirjutan lihtsalt error message is. Ta ütleb, et ta isegi ei aita mind Kuidagi nagu et saaks nagu tabida,
Õpetaja: Pole niukest muuta, et error Message eluolu.
Õpetaja: Ei Sa viitad meetodi nimele. Seda meetodit juba käivitatakse, kutsutakse välja, Miks ma tahaks kuidagi temale viidata Uuesti,
Õpetaja: Et nagu ringsõltuvus, et ole hea käivita. Noh, palun. Väga. Nii võib ka teha.
Õpetaja: Selle asja nimi on Rekursioon.
Õpetaja: Peaks Dissi kätte panema. Muidugi, sellisel juhul,
Õpetaja: mis nüüd juhtuks Nüüd lõputu loob
Õpetaja: See meetod käivitab. Ee käivitatakse see meetod siit, sellest Catch ist.
Õpetaja: See meetod tuleb siia. Paneb error responsi. Kogu sisu. Status koodi. Paneb status koodi. Sisu tuleb siia. Ifi et tingimused kattuvad Nelisada Neli error, Kood on kaks, kaks. Ütlen sellele, et ei. Sina saad justkui mingisuguse sisu. See on jaavascript. Meil on meetod, mis ei tagasta Siin Ütled, et. Kuule, ole hea. Käivita see meetod.
Õpetaja: Tuleme otsast. Peale. Tuleme siia, tuleme siia sisse. Käivitame jälle jälle. Jälle. Jälle lõpp. Kunagi See tingimus ei muutu.
Õpetaja: See sisu ei muutu. Kogu aeg on see sama error ja see meid ei aita.
Õpetaja: Me tahame saada Error responsist, Mis tuleb internetist? Seda sisu ja seda soovime toppida siia.
Õpetaja: See on see, missioon eesmärgiga, et see flowb alla sinna see sisu flow siia. Sisse.
Õpetaja: Siit vaadatakse, et on mingi sisu. Seda Tv I tuleb näidata. Näitame seda sisu kogu flow.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis nii ongi vaja teha, Ütlen, et Siin on ju minu vastus.
Õpetaja: Siia. Message isse. Ma tahan seda panna. Siis ma siia Kirjutan Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: punkt message.
Õpetaja: Ahhaa, mäletate, mis ma Ütlesin selle kohta iga kord, kui mingi reaktiivselt mingi alert tuleb, mida me peame hoolitsema.
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: me peame alati sellepärast muretsema, et iga Jumala kord. No okei, meil see. See asi vaata käivitub veel. Teeme seda hiljem,
Õpetaja: Näitan seda. Vahet pole. Ärme mõtle sellele. Vaatame, kas see asi töötab
Õpetaja: kui mina tulen. Ah, kuidas ma saan seda teha? Vaata, et Error It annaks.
Õpetaja: Kuidas?
Õpetaja: Noh, praegu. Stoplight vastab kogu aeg samamoodi
Õpetaja: kogu aeg. Vaata ta Errorit. Ei tule. Ju,
Õpetaja: Ma saan korra lihtsalt seda mängida. Nagu kuidas ma saan seda mängida?
Õpetaja: Jah, No ma teen seda Samamoodi. Ee, ma teen seda siit sõnu sõnumi saatmisest. Mäletate, kuidas me login? Iga tegime vastavalt sisule. Ütlesime, andsime kaasa. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Kuule, anna mulle Sisu. Vaatame korra seda teenust. Ee, palju aega on? Mingi paar minutit oli niimoodi. Vaata, et Kuule,
Õpetaja: Get Prefered Value. Kui username on admin, Siis pane sisu. Kui on error, siis on siuke Sisu Meil siin näites oli ka ju. Vaata, pärnut ei leita, on ju? Mis on Pärnu,
Õpetaja: Mis on Pärnu? City Id Kolm vist oli vä.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan ruttu kohe. Mis see on, pärnu? Kui ma teen lahti, näed pärnu. Mis ta ütles, Üks ütles, onju? Nii siis mul on vaja täpselt sama asja teha. Nagu hookust pookust, niukest osa on vaja.
Õpetaja: Preföör midagi, Ma tulen siia, see on. Ma ise teen. Ja oma komiitina. Te tulete lihtsalt järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, siia Headerisse on vaja öelda, et I prefer Something get prefer value.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina ei saa username i pealt otsustada vaid selle City Id pealt, mis tuleb sisse
Õpetaja: City Id pealt peab otsustama, et mida vaja. See on. See on alammeetod, mis praegult hetkel on ainult Location Services to Do kustutada. Vaata, see, ma tõstan selle Sama asja nagu siia.
Õpetaja: Mul on eraldi meetod, et otsusta Prefer value sisse. Tuleb City Id
Õpetaja: City Id väärtuse pealt. Otsusta, kui see on, Mis need teised? Mis on Okeid?
Õpetaja: Tallinn on?
Õpetaja: Tallinn on kaks.
Õpetaja: Kui on kaks, siis anna mulle
Õpetaja: Kurat, Kuidas ma tean, mis see on, Korra peab vistlight I piiluma.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul ei ole õrna Aa City It on ju kuskil Tallinn. Siis? Ei, ma pean korra vaatama Nüüd Päriselt Stop light. I ka, et see asi töötaks.
Õpetaja: Stop Light, Stop Light maailma kiirem program. Kus on Stoplight? Jaa, aga see on ka Kuskil peidus. Vä
Õpetaja: Stoplight. Tõstan ta pärast ettepoole.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, Vaata, mis on mul need seal. Ee, defineeritud. Stop light is,
Õpetaja: aga ma Vaatan ruttu, Ära Tagastab. Ee, pangaautomaatide asukoha info. See siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ma vaatan vastuse, et kakssada kahel on null kaks ja kolm, see on Kõik linnad. See on Tallinn. See on ee pärnu. Ja kui ma panen siia sisse ühe eksempli,
Õpetaja: siis on ee
Õpetaja: tartu, millega ei ole midagi, onju? Või Mida iganes, onju? Ehk siis, kui ma. Ma vaatan ruttu ära. Mul on vaja kõiki. See on ka variant. Tegelikult null. See tulebki alguses,
Õpetaja: Siis ma tahan saada niukest asja.
Õpetaja: Example null. Noh, nüüd ma saan selle paika. Näed,
Õpetaja: palun anna mulle sampel null, Numbrid on siin põhimõtteliselt. Kui on null,
Õpetaja: ehk kõik linnad, siis anna see, kui on. Kaks,
Õpetaja: Noh, kui on kaks, ma juba tean või on null.
Õpetaja: Te võite pausile minna.
Õpetaja: Kui on kaks, siis. Ja. Ja. Ja ei, seda ma ei tahtnud.
Õpetaja: Kui on kaks, siis anna mulle sample Kaks,
Õpetaja: kui on. Ee, Üks on veel juhataja, mis oli Okei, kui on kolm,
Õpetaja: siis anna mulle üks Apple kolm
Õpetaja: ja kõikidel teistel juhtudel Ehk siis pärnu. Ma ütlen, anna mulle lihtsalt viga.
Õpetaja: Mis on siis selline kood?
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru jälle. See on see fookus Fookus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd saab mängida.
Õpetaja: Ee, proovime. Kas töötab sellepärast, et sõnum saadetakse, et tuua neid asju ära.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis taustal praat ei muutu, on see, et Me ei ole ikka ju see A. Me ei tee seda, et ta käivitaks seda. Okei, ma panen lihtsalt siia. Ee, selle algväärtuseks.
Õpetaja: Panen Lihtsalt millega tuleb viga? Kolm vist vä või kaks. Kurat, mis see nüüd oli?
Õpetaja: Ee, üks On see ükstaspuha mitte. Igaljuhul null kaks ega Kolm on ju,
Õpetaja: et kui ma panen selle üheks,
Õpetaja: ei leitud ühtegi pangaautot. Meil ei ole see reaktiivsus veel tehtud Ära ei ole ju? Vaata,
Õpetaja: me ei tee mitte midagi. Väärtustame, aga me ei ütle. Okei? Viimane asi siis ka vaata. Teeme siis selle niimoodi ausalt, et ta juba töötaks, siis on nagu normaalne koht, kust I Love Optimizing ka. Ee, siis on normaalne koht. Kus on see koht? Vaata, kus
Õpetaja: Ee Midagi käivitub, Käivitab, kus sa oled? Ta on peidus kuskil siin.
Õpetaja: College. Tema käivitab praegu Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd hetkel ta ainult uuendab seda ja tuleb Alert või muudame selle meetodi nimel pärast ära. Mina nüüd ütlen, mis ma pean ütlema. Palun Get Locations,
Õpetaja: et ee Uuenda Selected City Id väärtust ja käivita uuesti. Get Locations, Too ära andmed.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ta reageerib Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Ta ei uuenda sind, midagi, Tartu.
Õpetaja: Aga kui paneme pärnu,
Õpetaja: ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati. See osa, et seda me pole üldse jõudnud teha Veel onju, et geneeri sööngi peale pausi.
Õpetaja: Võibolla viimane asi, et nüüd, Kas sa. Kas. Mida see meetod ütleb? Mida ta teeb?
Õpetaja: Et ta väärtustab selle elektrit City Id väärtuse ära.
Õpetaja: Aga kui mina, nagu vaataks seda seal kohas, kus on seda välja kutsutud.
Õpetaja: Noh, lähme siin ülesse. Näiteks, et tuleb. Event, mis toimub? Mida ta teeb praegu? Minuga
Õpetaja: Mida Sa meetode nimi teeb minuga praegu.
Õpetaja: Ta valetab mulle. Mida ta valetab?
Õpetaja: Ta valetab, et ta teeb midagi konkreetset asja, aga ta teeb natuke rohkem. Nüüd
Õpetaja: ta ei tee enam ainult seda, et ta City Id muudab ära, vaid
Õpetaja: ta muudab väärtuse ära ja toob uued andmed.
Õpetaja: Siis See meetodi nimi ju valetab.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ei näe seda koodilõiku, siis ta. Siis Ma ei tea, et ta valetab mulle, kui ma vaatan siia sisse, siis ma näen, et ta valetab. See on siis refaktureerimise kohta, et näiteks,
Õpetaja: Ee Get Selected
Õpetaja: City
Õpetaja: Locations sobib.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeb ju Seda
Õpetaja: täpselt on see. Vaata, et ee, mis ta teeb. Ta kõigepealt väärtustab ära selle väärtusega, mis tuli ja siis käivitab selle meetodi, aga See ju kasutabki siin
Õpetaja: sõnumi. Sealt Seda sama Id D.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta ei valeta vähemalt. Hea küll. Ja Bush Ja lähme sööme juttu ja pärast saame hakata lammutama selle
Õpetaja: tabeli kallal, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kas oli väga keeruline?
Õpetaja: Praegu vist oli keeruline. Ei. Kas mingid asjad hakkasid ka samas Mingeid asju avastasid, et saan paremini aru.
Õpetaja: Me lemmutasime siin meetodeid ja mingeid parameetreid ja kutsume välja, et see flow niimoodi vaikselt.
Õpetaja: Ee, mina Panen Stop Share. Panen rekordi ka kinni, et ta olekski täitsa stop. Ja siis pärast.